- I thought I would come
in here and I would be like
an instant, like everyone
be like, great blonde girl.
(laughing)
Just like do I need to be an internet,
do you wanna be an idol in
Japan, just take all the country!
(laughing)
- Life hits you like a truck.
(upbeat soft music)
- Hello and welcome to another episode
of the Trash Taste podcast.
I am your host for today,
Gigguk and with me are my usual
cohost, the boys you know who they are.
And with me, again as I'm
hosting, I have another guest.
Wow!
(cheering)
We have the beautiful Sydsnap
and I can say that. (laughs)
- Yes!
- But yes, do you want to
introduce yourself Sydney?
- Hey guys.
- It's Gigguk's wife.
- It's Gigguk's almost wife.
- That's what you are.
- Strongest intro I
have ever in any guest.
- Hey guys, you didn't
even say it's your girl.
- I was about to.
- Okay, go on and say it, say it.
- Hey guys.
- Okay, that's all you need to know.
- You can tell she's a girl.
(laughing)
- So you go by Sydsnap on YouTube.
- No!
- Okay, oh my God.
- So do you wanna explain
to anyone who is unfamiliar
with your content, what you kind of do.
- Okay so I have a YouTube
channel I usually talk about some
of the lunar things on the anime spear.
- That's a nice way of
putting it. (laughing)
- Most Christian way you
have ever (indistinct).
- Non-Christian time.
(laughing)
- Come over if you're feeling curious.
Talk about endo game,
manga, high penetration.
- And other beautiful, beautiful stuff.
- Just doing God's work.
- I wanna get right into it, what's--
- Let's just jump right into it.
- Let's not bit around the bush.
- Yeah, I'm just excited
to talk about this.
Can you explain what the
pussy of the round table is?
Right away, please.
(laughing)
- I've heard the name but
I'm yet to know its glory.
- This horrific contraption.
- No tell me I wanna Sydney all about it.
- It looks like a medieval torture thing.
(laughing)
- So I saw this thing I advertise online
and it was just like this giant fleshy.
It's this fleshy giant
roll of a bunch of pussies.
(laughing)
- There's no other way to describe it.
It's just like the dome.
- And you put it for a video to clarify.
- I did one of my videos
and where I'm just like sex
products in Japan that
are animatedly weird.
And it's just a bunch
of pussies of like girls
as they grow older.
- Likes six of them around.
- And you're supposed to
like take it with the boys
when you want to have a little party.
(laughing)
(indistinct)
- Invite the boys over for
let's have a nice group fuck.
- I remember you told
me something about it.
That was like it's in order of age.
- Yeah one of them's like,
cause it's your panty.
It's like elementary, middle
school, high school, adult.
- How far adult do we go?
(laughing)
- Grandma!
- Is that like a Grandma pussy at the end?
- It's like one of them just sagging down.
- Obviously it does. (laughing)
- It's just like a gaping hole. (laughing)
- It actually is.
- So that's a great first topic.
I just wanted to talk about that.
- I never thought to
myself, I need like an item
for the circle jerk.
Something's missing from
this circle, oh yeah.
- The thing is we've
always known about Japan.
Japan has like some weird ass toys.
- Everyone knows.
But like having moved here and really like
living with Sydney and
seeing some of the shit
she has to buy for her
channel, it's just like--
(indistinct)
(laughing)
- Gun point!
- Buy pussy of the round
table now, like do it.
- I thought my faith in
humanity couldn't get lower
than next week, it just like
lowers every single week.
Cause I remember this one time we were
in this like doujinshi shop
and she was like looking
for weird things to buy.
And then we just see this brain, right.
And I'm just like, why
are they selling a brain?
There's no reason why a shop
should be selling a brain.
And then we pick up the
box and we turn it over.
And it's just like this
brain that you can fucking,
like stick your dick in.
So it's a literal fleshlight
that's shaped like a brain.
- Oh some people wanna
brain fuck. (laughing)
Some people want a literal brain.
- It's so heavy.
- What worries me about the
round table of the you know
objects is that normally
if I wanted to fuck a brain
I'd probably do that in private.
I'm going to keep that to myself.
But there's someone out
there who is six homeys
who is like boys, I've got it.
(Garnt laughs)
And then they're all equally fucked up
and they've all told each other.
- How would you even position yourself?
- There's actually a diagram
that comes with the box
so like this there's an anal hole
like right at the box ones as well.
It's like, imagine this
like huge Play-Doh of like
with six pussies on display.
- Like a bar stool right?
- Yeah looks like a bar stool
and then there's a hole at the bottom.
So how it goes is that there's a guy
at the bottom and you put it
on a dick and then like six
other dicks can be fucking
this hole (laughs) on this guy.
- How is this episode already more lit
than the Shibuya Kaho episode?
- Parents are gonna be watching this.
- I wanna know how do you
go from a normal human being
functioning in society
to reviewing the pussy
of the round table on YouTube?
What's the origin story of that?
How do you get into that?
(indistinct)
(laughing)
I know you have seen voice acting online
cause we're in like the same community,
but how did it like go from...
How'd you get into voice acting
and then go into that
kind of side of YouTube.
- Are you asking how--
- Everything!
- The beginning of my life?
- Yeah.
- Yeah, yeah.
- Well I guess, so I started
out on YouTube when YouTube just began.
I was about 12, 13, and
I was a big anime nerd.
I was that girl, you know just
like call me Yumiko Kawagawa.
And I was like, what's the
best way to be the most closest
to an anime girl that you can.
And I was just like,
maybe being her voice.
So I tried and doing voice
acting and then I grew
up and I stopped doing
fandoms and abridge series.
- 'Cause you were pretty big
in the like bridging scene
back in the day, one year.
I remember because back when
bridging was like at its prime
you had like team four star
and then you had a lot of other
people were trying to emulate
what team four star were doing.
And we got to the point where
people started realizing,
hey if we use female voice actresses
we couldn't make our
abridge series look legit
because most of the bridge
series were just like--
- All dudes!
- Yeah all dudes.
(indistinct)
It would just be like the dudes
playing the girl characters,
doing that like best falsetto
or whatever it's called.
So if you had a female
voice actor that meant
your abridge series, like legit.
- Have a budget.
- The problem is that there weren't many
female voice actresses in the community.
So I remember like how I discovered Sydney
was she was like one of the
five female voice actresses
who were just like in everything.
So that's how I discovered you.
Like how was it back in the
day for you being like voicing
in so many different abridged series
in so many different paragraphs.
- 'Cause you're like first-generation,
like online voice acting.
- Yeah, I started when I was like 14.
I mean back then, obviously
I was kind of like around
when the boom of it kind of
began obviously when people
were just like, shit girls want a voice
in our terrible parity.
(laughing)
And so like I get a
lot of offers every day
because there's not many girls
who have like microphones.
- Oh, I guess my me and my blue Yeti.
(laughing)
- So it was like, I felt like hot shit.
- Like female voice actresses
were wanted commodity.
Just like, whoa.
So it was pretty fun, I felt
like a celebrity, like what?
You don't know who I am, I'm
in every abridged series.
- You go to like Walmart.
You're like, oh God (indistinct).
- They're staring at me
because they probably
know who I am just too
nervous to come up and ask.
(laughing)
- I forgot my fame sunglasses.
(indistinct)
- They know I was in that
fourth poker abridge.
Oh Jesus!
(laughs)
- So I gotta ask like were there a lot
of projects that you're in
that you maybe not so proud
of now, like looking back at it.
- I think you can say--
- With out naming.
You can read it without naming.
- That's how you know
someone's a good voice actor.
If they're like, yeah man I
love everything I have been in.
(indistinct)
That means you don't recognize
what some of the shit was.
- No, definitely there are
probably I'd say about like
a good, like 70%.
- 70% of the voice actor.
(laughing)
- Maybe I'd say even close
to 90, because very rarely.
And this is gonna sound terrible.
But like when I was in the parodies
I only laughed at say
like one or two, three.
None of them were funny, I'm sorry.
(laughing)
- Every abridger whose voiced with Sydney
it's just like, maybe I'm the 10%.
I'm the 10%, I could be the 10%.
- I'm funny right?
- Were you ever like casted in there?
Cause okay, if you were
one of the five female,
did you ever get like
casted in the project?
And then you're like,
cool, cool this is good.
And then you hear the other voice actors
and you're like how do I get out of this?
How do I back the fuck out.
- Of course because like
back then it's just like
there are like, oh you're a girl
even though you're using your laptop mic.
(laughing)
I've never acted before, but
it's just like of course.
But sometimes like I was
like, I'm unfortunately
one of those people that's
once I kind of offer something,
it's really hard for me to
say, I'm just not gonna do it.
It's really hard to say no.
So most of the time, it just...
- I'm like I gonna do the lines
but I'm not going to
do it with enthusiasm.
- I feel like that's just the best way
to practice from what I thought.
I mean, I'd say with lot of
things you just got to do
it even if you suck.
You're gonna suck for the longest time.
And then you eventually
learn how to do it.
- Just audition.
Just never stop auditioning
and then you'll get better.
- Yeah that's definitely
how it was back then.
It's like, even if it was
all shit, it's a practice.
- Yeah.
But yeah, so how did you try like what...
Did you ever stop voice
acting or is it something
you just kind of lost interest in?
- I mean, it kind of plays
into how we met, isn't it?
Like cause we met from his
abridge series, Ev Abridged
in case you guys couldn't guess.
- Oh my God, here we go.
- Almost married.
But once I, we started
dating, I actually moved like
after we started dating.
Like I moved to England and I started
going to school in England.
And I think from that point
I stopped voice acting
for a good few years.
But then I came back
because I was just like,
you said like you think I
should try and do YouTube.
And I'm like I don't know,
voice acting's not in the same community.
And you're like, maybe
don't do voice acting.
And I'm like what?
(laughing)
And then I started doing manga videos
because I really liked manga.
- Right.
- And I started noticing
like people tended to prefer
what I talked about some
of the looter titles,
it started off with like
JK HARO is a sex worker.
And so like, you know, Naval sex.
(laughing)
(indistinct)
- I think the big transition
was when you did your video
on euphoria, right?
- I feel like Garnt has all
the answers to these questions.
He like, no Sydney that's not
how it happened I was there.
(laughing)
Garnt is like human fact checker.
- He's the one who was,
actually I definitely
wouldn't be here if it wasn't for Garnt.
He like helped pave
the way kind of told me
what these like, hey this
might be a good thing.
And I'm like, I don't know.
And anytime I needed advice, he was there.
- Yeah, cause I remember when
I saw some of your thumbnails
I'm like, that's not the level
of click bait from someone
(indistinct)
(laughing)
for four months and I was like Garnt
did you make the thumbnails?
He was like yeah I did.
I knew it was too good bait.
- She had a private coach like that.
- Definitely.
But definitely I think I
started getting more attraction
when I started talking about it.
Cause I'm not going to lie I
like to play a good aerogel.
(indistinct)
Just playing a little euphoria and...
- I mean to arrogance
but I never had the
balls to try it before.
- Okay, okay.
- I know euphoria was...
Garnt was like, oh euphoria.
- Can I tell the story?
Let's put the mic in your face.
(indistinct)
Okay, how did you first
find out about euphoria?
- I heard somebody talk
about it, but I didn't really
like they didn't say
anything bad about it.
They just said, oh it was like
kind of like a death game.
And I really liked horror,
I like death games.
- I have no idea what this is by the way
I share this a lot of poop.
- Oh, okay we'll get into that.
So one day Sydney is just like
messing about on her computer
and she just casually asked me, hey Garnt
have you heard of this anime
hentai called euphoria?
I'm like, yeah why?
And she's like, I'm
thinking about playing it.
I'm like, oh okay.
That's a pretty infamous game.
And she kept asking me why?
Why is it infamous?
What's infamous about this game.
- It's like the same
energy as your Mom coming.
Like Garnt what is bang bros?
What is that?
(laughing)
- I don't have a subscription
to porn in my mail.
- What is X can you explain.
(indistinct)
(laughing)
- And so I just go, you know what Sydney
why not just download it and play it.
- Why would you say that?
- And see what happens.
- Because--
- It was already downloaded.
- And you love this woman.
(laughing)
- It's resulted in probably one
of my favorite Twitter threads online.
Cause I told her to document
her experience with it.
And so she has this Twitter thread
of her like fresh experience with euphoria
which we can probably pull up.
- Because I was so certain
that you were overreacting
I'm honest, that was so certainly
I've seen my fair share of a rogue.
I know I played black or Bible black okay.
(laughing)
I'm like, oh, somebody's just
going to like accidentally
puke or something.
And everyone is just
like, this is disgusting.
- Oh, the moment I saw that
Twitter thread being started
I was like, oh (indistinct)
- It is one of the few Twitter threads
where you can literally grab the popcorn
and just scroll down.
- There has never been
a more well-documented
like journey of someone losing their mind.
(laughing)
- Cause I think it was never the same
after you've played euphoria.
And you released that euphoria video.
I think that was like
your first really dive
into for degeneracy.
- Yeah, of course I played like a rougie.
Like I sometimes--
- Do you want to explain what euphoria
is to someone like Conner
and people who don't know?
- I have no idea what
euphoria is I just heard
this poop and eating it.
- I wish it was just it.
- I wish we could say that's the one.
- Can we do a YouTube friendly version
so we don't get complete confused.
- Okay so (groans) that was pukie.
- Which also appears in euphoria.
- I think essentially everything Rose
that you can even think of on the top
of your head in the next three
seconds, it's in euphoria.
So euphoria is a kind game where--
(indistinct)
(laughing)
- Sorry, carry on.
- So euphoria is a kind
of game where this one guy
who suddenly starts to realize
he's a sadistic mother fucker
who enjoys like girls pains.
Is stuck in a room with
like seven other girls.
And they give him like
acts that he has to do.
Otherwise they, somebody
dies and gets killed.
- Basically like "Saw".
- Essentially, but like eating shit.
And so like they have
essentially every weird tag
you could have like
diaper wearing and shiting
and you have to eat the
shit out of the diaper.
They have like--
- Is this a fairy convention?
(laughing)
Oh my God!
- Taking your thing to another level.
- Oh my God!
That sounds too much for YouTube
but I think I get the picture of how--
- We usually have a lot here.
- And so that defined your YouTube career.
- Unfortunately!
(laughing)
- So you've watched that
or you experienced it.
You're like, this is it.
- This is my peak.
- This is what we're going to follow.
- To be fair I made a video cause I'm like
I thought nobody else knew
that euphoria was this bad.
I thought they thought that
what I did, I thought everybody
else thought it was like a death game
and I'm like, I'm warning you guys
and too little did I know I'm
the fucking dumb over here.
- I mean someone had to experience.
- Yeah!
- I've just taken the L for everybody.
- One thing I'm sure a lot of
people would've been curious
about is obviously like your female
who's like very into hentai.
- I'm I?
- But like how did you get
into hentai originally?
Like what opens the gate for
you and what made it appealing
to you to like--
- Because the general consensus
is females don't read hentai.
- Yeah, exactly right.
- They don't watch hentai.
- But I guess like, let's
start from the beginning then.
It's just more of like in case you guys
didn't know I grew up or I was born
and raised in a small village
in Wisconsin, near Milwaukee.
And wouldn't you think it
they're pretty conservative.
So I didn't have a sex
education and I got all
of my sex education from
actually from yeah hentai.
(laughing)
- This is going like the
good Christian girl ruin.
- I had no idea that like
jizz looked like anything.
Like, I didn't know like stuff came out.
(laughing)
(indistinct)
I was 17 when I learned that jizz existed.
- Oh my God!
- I didn't even know
what a penis looks like.
- That's fucked they
didn't teach you that.
- Yeah, our sex education was
more of like stay abstinent.
(laughing)
Don't do it.
- Yeah I've seen a bunch of those right.
It's like you can either
teach sex education
or tell them to not just not
fuck and not do any of that.
- Yeah.
- We had a sex ed, but it wasn't sex ed.
It's more of like, but
so I actually learned
I didn't know that hentai
really existed until I...
It was actually very
similar to Garnt story
where I found a random link to Bible black
and I downloaded it.
And then I saw just like a
girl, like growing a dick
and I'm like, can girls do that?
(laughing)
- You know you weren't sex educated.
(indistinct)
- Like search how do I grow a penis.
- Like, guys can jizz
can girls grow dicks.
Is that just the thing that my parents
have just not told me.
- Not essentially.
But so I think from there
just my interest grew
because I just like, well this
is the only sex education.
(indistinct)
So then I just kind of
dived in and actually some
of it had the stories and
it wasn't just fucking.
And then just life changed from there.
- So what else like some early hentai
that you actually like properly enjoyed.
Cause as like a teenager,
I'm sure most guys
we had one purpose of why
we like got into hentai.
We didn't really care
about the plot that much.
- I still don't care about the plot.
- He still doesn't, but
someone from your perspective
I feel would have have
something different.
- Well, definitely when I first
started like watching hentai
in a raw game it was just to
get like, just kind of like
the what is this warm feeling in my pants.
But then (laughs) but then I started
like my first real erosion that I liked
was you made me do kisidi
and it was just like
about depression.
And just like and this
guy's just having sex
with these depressed girls.
And I'm like, oh my God, I'm having feels.
Well, my pants are warm.
(laughing)
- Oh my God.
- This is not going to
be monetized, no way.
- We're sorry.
We're sorry YouTube.
- We have sponsors on this episode.
- I hope neither of our
parents are watching.
- Oh my God.
- There's like a million
other ways you could frame it.
(laughing)
You didn't have to say
warm feeling in my pants.
It's like the worst way
you could have put it.
(laughing)
- Cool talk.
So yeah, essentially (foreign
language) was the first one
and then obviously Kata Washojo.
You know, I was like--
- Once with good stories.
- Good stories and then
I kind of started going
for like the generally like,
hey this isn't just sex.
This is a good plot.
You know, kind of like one
of those porns like you see
and it's like somehow one of those lines
just sticks with you.
- Yeah.
- I've never seen an actual porn
and I'm like damn this story's good.
- I mean the only like
quotable porn (indistinct)
is really like horrible one.
- Yeah, yeah you didn't get my cereal.
- I think she wants me to suck my dick.
(laughing)
- Wait I gotta ask Conner
have you ever watched
like a hentai and just
watch the entire runtime?
No skipping.
- No!
- No skipping just watching entire episode
without skipping not hitting that button.
- I'll look at the watch and
be like, I got 10 minutes.
I can watch the intro.
(laughing)
I got time I can watch the intro.
And then I'm normally just disappointed
and like I wish I just
didn't know your personality.
The characters normally I like regret
that I learned more about them.
- That means you haven't
seen the good ones yet, yeah.
- I think I've seen some good ones.
- Like?
- I wanna out myself, yeah.
- What's like a peak of life.
- You gotta say it for the hentai episode.
Because we want to do that.
- We want to do like a hentai team--
- Gigguk's favorite hentai
so I'm gonna save it.
You know, I've got to
keep some Macy's in there.
- Well then while Sydney's
here, then what is yours?
Like what would you say
is like the absolute peak
of like yes, this is the
best one I have seen.
- Yeah.
- To be fair,
I don't watch a lot of
like animated hentai
because you know once you've seen one
honestly kind of seeing them all,
like it all looks the same.
- They are all based
off the dogens though.
- Yeah.
- Lots of them are based on variegate.
And like, even if they
were based off the Dogens
it was like Irma, like hentai
manga it was just like,
kind of like it doesn't
keep the good shape.
It not as beautiful.
- It doesn't keep the plot.
- It doesn't keep the plot
and even the sex scenes
that they copy that are
like hot in the dogens
aren't hot in animated form.
- Yeah I don't know.
Especially some dogens,
especially that if they're
animated by Queen Bee.
- Oh my God, do not talk about Queen Bee.
- I don't know how Queen Bee can take some
of the like best dogens like SA dogens
and make it seem like worstly animated
than fucking manga itself.
- There've been so many where
I like I'm into the idea
of the story I'm watching the cut scenes.
And then I forget I'm
still watching Queen Bee.
And then there's the two P and G start
rubbing against each
other and I'm like, oh!
- Some Queen Bee stuff I've seen is like,
they must've animated this on PowerPoint.
There's no animation.
- The worst thing about Queen Bee
is that they're like the
posters they look so good.
Queen Bees is a hentai
studio quite infamous
if you watch enough hentai
for just having the worst
animation you can imagine.
- If you've watched the
hentai and you thought wow,
this looks awfully shit.
Its probably Queen Bee.
- We are not gonna get that
sponsor from Queen Bee.
(laughing)
- I don't wanna be sponsored by Queen Bee.
- That's a badge of disrespect.
- I think Queen Bee was one of
the first studios that forced
me to like research hentai
studios because normally
hentai animation isn't the greatest.
But it's like, it's possible.
But Queen Bee was so bad that
it forced me to have to Google
search why does this
hentai videos look bad.
Oh, okay it's because the same,
it's because the same
studios are animating it.
But yeah, going back to you.
So what are some hentai you would probably
recommend not animated then?
(indistinct)
- Are we gonna fucking go down there?
Okay so--
- Yeah we're going down the
ramp we've already like--
- We've already gone down.
- We've already fallen down.
- Get close to the microphone
you're pretty far away.
I can see on the--
- Fuck okay.
- Like that, yeah.
- This episode is sponsored
by Bandai Spirits.
- And today they brought us the upcoming
that time I got reincarnated
as a slime Banpresto box.
- That's a hefty boy.
- That's a big thing, that's a big point.
Ooh, baby.
What's in the box Conner,
what's in the box.
- Open the box, what's in the box.
- I'm glad you asked
what's in the box Garnt
cause I don't know yet.
So should we find out in the box together?
- What's in the box.
- God stop!
- What's in the box?
Look at this little thing.
- Is that a rimuru?
- Its a rimuru!
- Rimuru I did not
pronounce that correctly.
- Oh, this was so good.
- Let me feel that.
- Its actually really soft.
- Oh, okay, okay very nice.
- Oh, so this is rimuru large plush.
It's 20 centimeters or 7.9 inches.
And it feels great in your
hand, you put it on your head.
You can put it on your shoulder.
You can put it anywhere.
Look at this, this is like...
How can you feel stressed holding this?
You know what I mean?
- And there's also this,
what does this Joey?
- Oh, that is the mascot
plush special color version
which is another exclusive
item for this Banpresto box.
- It's got a little key chain as well.
So you can clip it onto something.
- It is a key chain.
- Oh, look at this beauty.
I just got to shit out this beautiful.
Look at that oh my God.
- [Conner] Oh, that looks
similar to the one that we have.
- Rimuru is looking
cleanest, except this one
is the Esq figure, special color version.
And this also isn't exclusive items.
- That base is so cool
- That is really cool.
The colors, but wait there's
more, we're not done here.
There is two key chains
I'm seeing in here.
Am I reading this right,
yeah there is two key chains.
- Right there is two rubber key chains.
- We have a rubber key chain
of a cool looking rimuru
and slammed together.
And another key chain with
rimuru with these mask.
- That issues his mask.
- Yeah I told you didn't see that for us.
- That's cool.
- Then there's one more
item in here, gentlemen.
- That's super cute.
- That's so cute.
- I like how it like flushes.
- It got the round shape of the slime.
Yeah, but that's a exclusive for me.
It's a cute little slime mug right here.
Oh, I like the shape actually.
- And the value of all of this is $60 USD
but the best part is
gentlemen, it's only 29.99.
- Only 29.99
- That's our price.
- 29.99.
(laughing)
- Excited about this thing.
- I can't believe it.
- So some of these products
can only be sold in Japan.
So you can't get it in
North America at all.
- So if you want to get your
hands on this special box
go to premium Bandai USA or click
the link in the description below.
And this box is only available
until November 24th, 2020.
So it get your hands on it quick.
- Again, thank you very
much to Bandai Spirits
for sponsoring us today,
back to the video.
- Well, obviously if we're
gonna go down this route
I honestly prefer if I'm
going to be reading hentai
or like or hentai dogens or hentai manga.
Like so I guess--
- What's you go to tag?
- High penetration?
- Yes, definitely.
- Medium penetration? (laughs)
- It depends on the days.
Sometimes I'm looking for like virginity.
(laughing)
- Sometimes I'm feeling just to be pure.
- If feel awesome like,
I'm gonna get myself.
And then sometimes I'm just
like, what's the most--
- Skull fucking, skull
fucking only skull fucking.
(indistinct)
- I want a position of power being abused.
(laughing)
- Through the eye socket.
- But yeah do you have
like specific titles
that you recommend to people?
- Obviously anything by
Putsy, which is a hentai manga
artists and she's also having an anime
being released but it was delayed.
- It was supposed to come
out last season, I guess.
- She obviously, the anime
getting, animated for it.
- She's the artist who did
the art for male ISA guy.
If I remember correctly and
the elder sister Doujinshi.
(indistinct)
Oh, okay.
- But it's not going to be
the hentai version of that.
It's gonna be the more...
- Is that the turn girl.
- No!
- No you're talking about
Nanashi who did Nana Torah.
(indistinct)
- Nanashi is also a hentai artist.
- But if I'm completely honest
I always like to go to series
that are like of characters that are like
in the games I'm playing.
Like I like playing like
harvest moon and rune factory.
And sometimes I like to see the characters
like to marry and have
sex with my character.
(laughing)
- Well, I guess that's just
like the appeal of doujinshi.
- I've never played a
video game and thought man,
fuck I just want to see
Zephyroff take a huge dick.
- No, you're lying.
- You look that shit
there's probably thousands.
- I don't know because do you
guys remember the very first
doujinshi that you ever read.
- I have never read a doujinshi.
- You have never read a doujinshi?
- Never read.
- Never read a doujinshi!
- Conner has told me that he
can't get off to drawn porn.
- No, it's like just, I
had to play more chance
like fucking masturbating to like money.
Like the queen.
(laughing)
It's doing the same thing for me.
You know what I mean?
Like I need some fucking
movement going on.
- So do you need, is it the movement?
Is it the noise?
- Literally masturbating the
same way they did like 1800
when the camera was first invented.
Like oh God, my wife that
I haven't seen in 40 years
'cause I went to the war.
Oh, I'm gonna bust out the trenches.
- You're never like,
did you never like look
at like the Playboy magazines
and think like, that's hot.
- Yeah, I did but then I
realized like moving porn
was also an option.
How can you go back?
It's like the episode of South Park
where like they lose internet
and then they take turns
on like the PC masturbating to porn.
(laughing)
- I guess this, cause for me
like I remember the very first
time I discovered doujinshi
were her thing where,
you'd watch these anime and he'd be like,
this anime goes like kind of hot,
but of course, because it's an
officially licensed product.
You don't get to see any porn of that.
- I've never felt that way about anime.
I've never seen anime and be like man,
I wanna see these characters get fucked.
- What the fuck is wrong with you.
- Really?
- No.
- Even as like a kid,
have you never had like
a childhood crush on like a girl?
- But I've never like wanted
to like, cause to me it feels
like I don't know this is weird.
But I like it when my porn
is separated from the stuff
I enjoy, but you know what I mean?
I want it completely isolated.
- I get that.
- So I can cut that off and
nothing in my life changes.
Like, that no nut challenge we stopped
levitating after a month.
Like if I want to cut that
out it's not going to affect
like, you know if I'm looking
at Micasa porn every week
and then I'm gonna be
watching an attack on Titan
I'm gonna be like damn, I've
seen it get digged down.
(laughing)
- I get that though
cause I don't read dogens
of series that I like.
- Right, cause you want--
- I read dogens of series
I actually don't like.
- Put like the characters are
hot and you don't like them.
- Yeah because I don't care.
- I get that.
- The characters are good
looking but I don't care enough
about their personality
to see them get digged in.
- Yeah I would never want to read hentai
from a show that I like enjoy.
- I kinda get that.
- I'm the weird one here.
- No, there's a lot of
people who are like,
I love this character
therefore I want to see
them get digged down.
- I get it but I don't follow it.
- Okay!
- That's why like, I fucking love,
Salt Online or Emo like Love Life.
Because I don't care about
these characters enough
but they're all good looking characters.
(indistinct)
- I don't wanna be personally
invested in their lives.
I'm watching a porno, I'll
watch it and be done with it.
- No, I want like being
personally involved.
This is gonna sound so
fucking insane right now.
(indistinct)
Being invested in porn, just like elevates
it to like like newer heights.
That's why I like porn.
That's why I like plot with my porn.
- But at the end of the day
I feel like you're putting up
more barriers for entry to have
a good just wank at the end.
You know what I mean.
- But that wank is worth it though.
(laughing)
It's like the best one you're gonna get.
- No, because I get, if I watch dogen
or I read a dogen of a
character that I really like
or a series I really liked
the next time I have anything
to do with that series
in the back of my mind
I'm just like, yeah,
I'm thinking about it.
And it completely puts
me out of the experience.
(indistinct)
- How also is that like,
why do you want to put work
on yourself by reading and
having to imagine the rest?
You know what I mean?
- You have to imagine the rest is--
- It's not every single
little frame in your mind
is not playing out.
- That means you've read shit dogens.
- Yeah.
- I've never had any.
- I don't know it's like, let's just say
is all sex the same to you?
- Okay why do you, okay
is could get way to do.
(indistinct)
- The same reason why anyone does the act.
- Half the time I just do it
because I got nothing better.
I'll be honest with you.
I got like 10 minutes to kill.
I don't want to do the
tasks that I've set myself.
Like I gotta make this
thumbnail, I don't wanna do it.
- So you just do it to waste time.
- Yeah!
(indistinct)
- Kind of like whatever
I got five minutes men.
Just five minutes for every one.
I want to have a quick,
like a danger wank whatever.
(laughing)
But it's like most people the act of doing
it is a physically pleasurable.
- For me I just feel like it
cleans my mind, I don't know.
I feel like it's like
a reset, like a save.
(indistinct)
- You're talking like a
fucking now for some reason.
(laughing)
- I feel clean, I feel cleansed.
- You go in your bedroom,
it's midday you feel dirty
that you're kind of like do it.
And then you're like, all
right and then you do it.
Then you come out like levitate.
(indistinct)
- Its just like reset the
game, like in the game
or turn off the console
and turn back on it.
- You got like 20 Chrome tabs
open the shit is really slow.
You're like fuck it,
I'll just restart the PC.
Like that's what it's like.
- Why won't you just close the tabs?
- I mean it's so laggy you know,
and you fucking restart it.
- So like you've never really cared about,
you never cared about it.
- No.
- Yeah well, that's why I
guess I would understand
because I felt exactly the same.
And then I remember the first
time I read the doujinshi
about characters, not
characters I cared about
but I guess characters,
I was like invested
in maybe like getting
together because okay.
I'm guessing neither of you
or neither of anyone here went
through like the fan fiction phase?
- No.
(laughing)
- I have.
- Have you?
- I went through the
harvest moon fan fiction.
(laughing)
- What you and the other
three people out there.
- Because there would be times
when I would like be watching
an anime and I'll be like,
man I really want this
couple to get together.
It'd be really (exhales deeply)
I'm showing a new side of my degeneracy.
(indistinct)
But yeah I remember the
first time was during
like Hara Mongo, where
there would be this like
like obviously there
would be a winning girl
and be like, but what would
happen if the other girl won.
What would happen if the other girl won?
- I have to agree with that.
(laughing)
- Do you not feel like
you're like wasting time?
- Why, why?
- I've had that exact thing, words like,
cause when I was in like teenage years
I was heavily invested in To Lover.
- Yeah.
- I fucking love that.
But like at the time I was
reading it, there wasn't like
a clear winner, but there were
lots of potential winners.
I wanna know if...
What if he got with this
girl, what would it be like?
- Because what got me into the doujinshi
is there are so many anime we've
liked this romantic subplot
that goes fucking nowhere, right.
And I just want to see
the ending of that supply.
(indistinct)
- I understand the show
not being satisfying,
but to me it's like I wouldn't
want a story by an author
but to them it just be someone's
like I got it from here.
You know what I mean, to me that's weird.
That's why I've never been,
get my head around fan fiction.
Why would you want someone
else to write the story
that like, because someone
else would really know.
- Because if you don't have,
if you can't get the
satisfaction from the official
products, you just have to
search that out somewhere else.
It's not like--
- I'm just like fine with it
not having that satisfaction.
- I don't wanna be bothered
to imagine them myself.
Therefore, (indistinct)
- For example if there was say...
I'm going to bring it up again.
But if there was like
domestic girlfriends doujinshi
I don't need that shit
because they fucking fuck,
in like the actual series.
So like why, why would I need fan fiction.
- I've never watched an
anime and been like damn
I really need to know
what would happen based
on a third party's opinion of
what could happen if X person
got, you know what I mean?
That sounds weird to me.
I dunno, it doesn't
make sense, does it not.
Am I crazy guy here?
- I think we're both the crazy ones.
We're both on like two ends of the extreme
where I sometimes it's like
an itch that I can't scratch.
Where like if there's a
series where I know I'm never
gonna see these people get
together or this author's
never going to finish it the way
that I would like to finish up.
That my girl that I want
to win is not gonna win.
Then I'm gonna search
out the best way possible
how to itch that scratch.
And it's not just the doujinshi...
- Is that scratch.
(laughing)
- I can relate a little bit
I remember when I watched
Code Geass first time I was like
why did Lelouch ever fuck C2.
- Yeah, yeah.
- Therefore you go out and see it.
- And they're all fucking Doujinshi.
- They would definitely do that.
- I bet there was I just didn't care.
I wanted him to do it,
cause I'm like homie.
Yeah, cause you're taking over the world
let a little stress out
there had awesome pizza
(indistinct)
- Here is the thing right.
Here's the thing I can't read a doujinshi
for like every series.
There are certain series that I think
are fucking made for doujinshi.
And then I see like one
piece doujinshi and I'm like
why would anyone want
to get off with this?
That doesn't seem very (indistinct)
- One that makes sense right?
Cause there is so much
sexual attention around.
- I didn't mention, I
was just saying names.
- You're a stupid fuck.
- And I didn't care about
manga cause dogens are fucking lit.
- I dunno, I can't get my head around it.
Maybe someday I will.
- I feel like you just
need to see the good ones.
- You just need to grow a bit.
I actually remember--
- This whole podcast is Conner
you just need to try the good thing.
- Once you find the perfect tag that's it.
It's game over.
- This is why I don't
get into any more hatches
I just feel like I'm
going to lose more time
and I don't wanna waste any more time.
- Well you're using that
time to jack off anyway.
So it's like--
- I spent 10 minutes max jacking off.
- Yeah you can spend that
10 minutes reading dogens.
- No, that's too much time.
(laughing)
- Because you've gotta go
through find one that you want
and I bet you probably
have that thing as well
where it's like Netflix
where you're like fuck,
which one do I want?
- Okay here's the thing, most of the time
when I discover a good hentai
is by complete accident.
- How are you finding this?
- Cause like, normally I'm
just like, skip, skip, skip.
And I'm like--
- Skip on what?
- Like the random page or
like I find like a dogen.
And sometimes I like
give it like five minutes
if it's like a anime.
But if it's like, I'm less
likely to give it a chance
if it's an anime, cause
we've liked doujinshi
you can read way faster.
You know?
It's like one on YouTube, you
hear that 1.5 speed button
when you're just like I
wanna see what happens.
When I can't be bothered
to like hear everything
at this exact space.
- Do you ever just like, you
just can't find a good one
so you're just like fuck it.
I'll just get off to one of
them, I just find it weird
because like this just take me too long.
- No, because I know how
to find the good ones.
- All right, fair enough.
- But sometimes it comes
like a complete accident
where I start reading.
I'm like, oh this has got some character
development on there.
Like maybe I'll give it a--
- Let's do it for a second.
I know there's some character development.
(indistinct)
- If there's like 10 pages.
If the 10 first pages go
by and there's no fucking
you know, the author has given thought
into the story of this dogen, man.
You know what I'm talking about Joey.
You know what I talking about
don't pretend like you don't.
- Unfortunately do.
(laughing)
- That's always the big tale
when it doesn't start off
by fucking straight away, then
you know there's a chance--
- I'm like this guy actually cares.
- Yeah, they actually care.
And then I dunno, being
invested in a story
like that's kind of how
I got into Nozoki Ana
and a lot of other titles that have like--
- A soft core stuff.
- Yeah, like the soft core
stuff that have sex in them,
but also have a really good plot
that you can get emotionally invested in.
- Have you ever gotten to
the anime through the dogens?
- Yes.
- Have you?
- What?
- Have you ever gotten into an anime
because you saw a dogen?
- Absolutely.
- Even if you haven't seen the anime.
- Yes!
- Which one?
- Okay I remember I actually
read Code Geass dogens
before I watched it.
(laughing)
(indistinct)
- I'm trying to think which one was it?
(laughing)
No, no.
It's hard for me because
again the only dogens I read
that are parodies of anime are
the ones are the anime series
that I didn't enjoy.
So say C8 that like space,
I read the dogens for it.
Well, I don't know if there
is one that was the opposite.
I'm sure there is but
they're probably just like,
not, not, not, yeah
they're not worthy series.
- But I guess that's like
the difference between just,
you know having a quick 10
minute jack up session to...
My God this is like the most
degenerate God damn podcast.
- If you're watching this
with your parents, I'm sorry.
- No one talks about this,
but we all experience
this and then no one
wants to talk about it.
I don't give a fuck, well everyone wanks,
let's be honest it's 2020.
- Everybody wanks.
- Everyone wanks.
- Put that on the show.
- Make it a song.
- Make it a song everybody wanks.
- So I gotta ask what is
the most messed up one
that you would say, that
you would be like...
- It's hard actually, that's hard
because obviously some of them
do try to be really fucked up
and it's just like, kind of
comes off as like crunchy,
like Oh my God, you're fucking nuts.
Girls intestines, like, come on.
Like you're just trying too hard.
But some of them are just like,
oh, I didn't know you could do that.
(laughing)
- Because there's an entire
genre for that, right?
(indistinct)
- That's something that like
even I don't wanna touch man.
- I don't like it like that.
- I've been trying to dive
into that side of things
just because no one else
wants to just like how bad.
- For good reason.
- For good reason, how bad could it be?
I'm like the little that
I've seen I'm just like,
I understand now. (laughs)
Yes, this is bad.
- But this is something where
if I see some like arrow girl
I have to like completely separate myself
from like that work.
And just view it as like a piece--
- I'm soft as a pillow
whenever, (indistinct)
I don't know how I'm open to a lot
of different sexual things.
Like, different fetishes that you do you.
Aragora though if you're into that shit,
don't come near me.
Don't come near me.
- I don't even think that like
incognito mode can save you.
- There was a, okay so I was also trying
to get into it'll aragora probably try
and make a video on it.
So in Japan, when I was
at a doujinshi store,
they had like these
magazines that are actually,
I didn't know till later were quite famous
for eroguto which is called erogutos.
Do you know them?
- Yeah, yeah.
- And I read one and of
course it's in Japanese
so I didn't fully understand everything
but I will say the dead baby
stuff is not my favorite.
(laughing)
- Fuck!
What!
- Dead baby staff isn't good.
- I don't think we need to go any further.
- Probably end there.
- What the fuck!
- I need to wait for
Sydney to make a video
if it eventually get there.
But I totally get what
you mean like some dogens
that are just like
trying to be way too edgy
or just like, come on, like
we know you're trying it.
But then there are the
actually fucked up stuff
like metamorphosis for example, right.
Like I reckon like if
there was one, I'd still
say that's my favorite dogen,
even though it completely
fucked me up the first time I read it.
- It your favorite?
- Yeah, it's my favorite because...
it's my favorite cause I
dunno, I like a lot of stories
that have quite depressing
where like you watch a character
go from--
- Sad wank on.
- No, no, no, no because that's the thing.
It was like an--
- Existential wank.
(laughing)
- Why am I here?
Metamorphosis was the first
time where I was like,
I was prepared to go in for a wank,
but then I had to let go
and be like okay, hold on.
- Zipper going up.
- Yeah zipper going up
because I'm soft right
before, but for a good reason right.
Because that story is like I mean,
I'm sure Sydney can vouch
for this or whoever has read
metaphor sis can vouch for this.
But it's like, it's a dogen
but it goes beyond a dogen.
Like how do you find it?
- I definitely, when I first
cause when I first heard
of it, I was actually, I
think from hockey's video
when she made a video just
saying oh, it's really messed up.
And I'm like, okay, I think
I've been around the block
but no, I definitely wasn't
expecting like majority.
Because I also am a big
fan of depressing things.
(laughing)
- A big fan of depression,
I like the work he does.
- And so when I, yeah Noah.
So when all that started
happening, when she graduated
and all that, you know--
- We weren't go into detail.
- I was definitely set, once
I finished it I just sat
looking at the ceiling on the bed.
Just like, where am I?
What did I do?
(laughing)
- What did I do to deserve
to be here right now?
- What did I do wrong in my life?
- What I think about metamorphosis
it's likely a yummy pinpoint of hentai.
- It is!
- You know what I mean?
- Straight up is and I
think that's why I love it.
(laughing)
(indistinct)
- What the fuck happened to you.
Jesus Christ!
- No, cause I did,
I interviewed Shindol, the
crater of metamorphosis
and I asked him, but I obviously
had to ask him about that.
And he said it in a really cool way,
which is like I wrote that
story not to give this entire
shock value of like I
wrote a messed up dogen,
but because he was raised in America,
he's like I've seen so many
people whose lives end up
like this and I wanted to
show it not to like fetishize
it so much but more so to show off,
like this can happen to people.
And if you find this like hot
or attractive than this kind
of something wrong with you.
I'm not showing it as a type of feedish.
I'm showing it as like,
he's basically like,
I'm throwing out a message, right?
It's about sending a message. (laughing)
- Hentai is art, that's
what I'm trying to say.
- He gave the hentai like, I
wrote that because I wanted
to show it off in an artistic way.
And for the first time I
was like, you know what?
That didn't sound pretentious.
Wow, you're one of the
first people who were like,
okay I totally get it
cause I was the same thing.
When I read it, I was
like, is this just edgy?
Or am I thinking about this
like way too artistically.
But then when you finish
reading you're like okay.
No, it is actually quite autistic.
- Yeah, yeah definitely
- You should read it. (laughing)
- How long is it?
- It's like--
- A 100 and something pages.
(indistinct)
It's one volume.
- Yeah it's one volume.
- Yeah, because the thing is,
the thing I've been wondering
recently is hentai has become
this like buzz word right.
Where we use it to describe it.
We use it describe anything
that kind of involves
like titis or sex nowadays.
But like, do you feel
like there's a difference
between just hentai,
like porn, unlike erotica
with like good like things
that have good plots
but also just happened to have sex.
- Yeah absolutely.
- Because I think the
whole hair hentai art thing
that's you know, that we kind of promote
is that it's not so much that we think
that this is like jack off material.
We just think that just because it has sex
in it doesn't necessarily
mean that this is just porn.
- That's you guys not me.
- Well, I mean like this is
like, why does a lot of autistic
film you sex as like a way to--
- That's fine I'm not
gonna like bust out my dick
in the cinema when I see a sexing.
- Yeah.
But I think the whole like hentai is odd.
Stems from like, oh, it's
good titis and therefore
(indistinct)
- The way that I judge it
is if I type in free hentai
and the website has like 10
pop-ups I'm like, this is porn.
If there's not at least five
popups, it's probably not porn.
- Yeah, like I'm not
gonna like play con wars
and be like, oh this is (indistinct)
(laughing)
Like yes, I love the artistic innovation.
- I think it's just like the images
they get shattered on on
Twitter most of the time
there are just artists just drawing light
either just stills of
something or whatever.
Like just hot, I like those.
Those are nice, those are arts.
I would never like sit, get on the train
and get like a Chubb at seeing
like a Twitter art of like a sexual.
- Oh no, no, no.
- But it's like, I'm like nice.
But I mean you guys would
write cause you read
your dogens and so (laughs)
- It's just a picture wouldn't be enough.
- Yeah.
(indistinct)
- I don't crack a fat every time.
Like every time I'm like,
oh yeah there's some nude
let me just like it.
- I sat next to the train
on Joey at rush hour.
I'm like Joey I can feel
it stop watching hentai.
- You see me on a pack trains
like hand-tight on my Twitter.
- I need the semen bank fucking
bull if I would say like,
if I had to jack off every
time I saw a little bit
on my Twitter timeline, man.
Jesus Christ (indistinct)
You'd be jacking off every
like every other second.
Basically.
- It's gotta be a challenge right?
It's like you see a nude on
Twitter you gotta jack off.
(laughing)
- You have to finish.
- It's like the opposite
of no nut November.
- Only nut November.
- We got to like to your counter movement.
- I like how this conversation completely
just delved into just like--
- We should go back to YouTube stuff
on Sydney's origin story. (laughs)
We'll save for the hentai episode.
- We can talk about this forever.
- Yeah it's like a straight hour.
Like is hentai really art?
- No, no!
- This is the most civilized discussion
we've had on Trash Taste.
- I remember when we
were discussing one time
and then me and Garnt
were there and it was you.
And then I think you
were like, no people come
for me from all my super
serious anime takes.
I looked at Garnt and I'm like, what?
- No, you said, because then you're like,
oh people come to you because
they like your personality.
- [Conner] Yeah!
- No but they want my recommendation.
- I looked at Garnt and I'm like,
no back me up man, back me up.
- A year and a half ago--
- I think you were still
getting the fill for it.
But even then felt that your
videos that were recommending
stuff it was still like people
came for your personality
not for the recommendation.
- Obviously yeah.
- Recommendations died
like five years ago.
- Nobody actually seeks
recommendations on you.
- No, no, no.
I want to just be
entertained for 10 minutes.
I do have to think about my day.
- I mean, the recommendation
comes as like a plus
you know what I mean?
To whatever the personality
who is presenting.
- If I'm honest I mean, I
personally I don't think
I'm anything you can't get
anywhere personality wise,
but I don't call, I don't
want them to think of it.
But that's what just want to say it like.
(laughing)
- Way to assume.
- Both of you to assume.
(indistinct)
- Fuck you!
(laughing)
No, but then, and that's
why it gets like in a way--
- I just think anyone who
starts YouTube right away
in the first like year thinks
of themselves as a personality.
Like they think alike.
Oh, I'm just doing stuff about
anime, it's all about me.
- I mean it's something
you'd definitely grow into.
I can't remember how long it's it took me.
Cause it took me forever,
Sydney you've been doing YouTube
for like how long now?
- Two years almost.
- Oh my God you're a YouTube child.
(laughing)
- For this kind of content obviously.
- With this kind of content.
- Yeah but two years,
two and a half years something like that.
- How has your journey
been in that two years
growing and finding--
- Honestly I think
I started to accept, it's
like kind of like at first
initially I'm like, I don't deserve this.
It doesn't feel like I've
done anything really.
Up until recently I had really bad.
- I still get imposter syndrome.
I'm like, why are people
even like subscribing to me?
I'm just like really
loud talking about titi.
Like I just say titi every
like 50 times in one minute.
And, but I guess recently,
I guess I'm just starting
to see like maybe I'm
not such a piece of shit.
(laughing)
- Self confidence!
- I think everyone feels impulsive.
- Yeah.
- Like when another big
crater that you maybe
respect is like, yo, I love your stuff.
You like (laughs).
- Oh my God yeah.
(indistinct)
All the fucking time is like
oh I love, I like your videos
and like stop trying to suck my dick.
I know you don't.
- I remember I had, I remember who it was.
I got a DM from someone they're
like, I like your videos
and I was, I was gonna reply
but I was thinking about it.
I was panicking I'm like,
are you fucking with me?
(laughing)
They like are they joking
or they're poking fun at me.
(indistinct)
- It's always from that one
issue that you'd never thought
you'd associate.
- Yeah!
- Is like why are you on my channel?
- I fucking love your videos, man.
You're like, your lying.
- Every time I hear a
compliment my first reaction
is just why are you lying to me?
- Yeah like what do you want?
(laughing)
(indistinct)
- By being British I just
assume they're being sarcastic.
Like where's the punchline,
just tell me the punchline now.
Just get it over with, I
don't want to hear the rest.
- Please say psych.
(laughing)
- Thank you Book Walker for sponsoring
this segment of the video.
Did you know that it is
Book Walker 5th anniversary
this October!
(cheering)
(clapping)
Thank you Book Walker.
- Happy birth day to daddy Book Walker.
- So we're just going to
take 10 minutes very quickly
to talk about some of our favorite manga
on Book Walker as they're sponsoring us.
- We're just going to
do a 10 minute segment
where we talk about manga,
who doesn't love manga right?
- Looser!
- You know my favorite (laughs).
- This man is gonna do it.
- You know my favorite
manga on Book Walker is?
It also has an audio book
counterpart to go with it.
Did you know it's one of the
best-selling books on audio,
fuck on Book Walker.
It's your my princess
audio book by C doggy
I think in the credits.
- Who is that?
- Who is that right?
An upcoming porn star.
- Is this you? (laughs)
Is this you?
- Whose mans?
- If I haven't showed it enough already.
Whatever.
- Just go for it.
- Just buy it. (laughing)
Buy it I mean the critics say
it's good and it's got five
star rating on Book Walker.
- Really?
- Yeah, it had a four
and a half at one point.
I watched that like a whole.
Who gave a four star, it's five
now though so everything's been fixed.
So I got mailing to fix that right up.
I didn't, I didn't, I didn't, I didn't.
It actually went back up on it's on.
I'm checking, why am I surveying?
All right, what's your favorite
manga I Book Walker boys?
Or visual novel I think that's some
of the most popular ones.
(indistinct)
- You called it visual novel
it's just a preference.
- I'm a fake fan.
(laughing)
- Can we cut that and redo that.
What's your favorite not visual novel.
They also sell light
novels as well as manga.
I believe that some of the
most popular stuff on there.
As I don't really know where
else you can buy light novels.
- We constantly buy light
novels legally in any other
website, from my understanding at least.
- So support the industry.
- Yeah It's been a great place
to read light novels there.
That's where I read the
(exhales) fuck sake.
(laughing)
- My favorite one, which
I forgot the name well.
- I did actually forget the name of it.
- I feel like I get a
glimpse into what animates
are gonna become because
normally the most popular
light novels I see just,
I'm like that's an anime.
- I go into Book Walker and I see
like the most popular light
novel that I don't know the name
of and I'm like, that's
going to be an anime soon.
It usually happens.
- What was It?
Not a manga Glepair, I don't know.
I remember that was big on Book Walker
and I was like turn it to anime.
I was like, oh I knew that.
That's the one (indistinct)
- If I can give a sweet boy recommendation
also, I just wanna say that you said boys
but I'm also a female so?
- Boys and girls?
- Everyone is a boy.
- So Sydney, what's your
favorite manga slash
light novel on Book Walker.
- I mean there is just
to much pick from guys.
(laughing)
- Is that okay Meilyne?
Is that you, can you put the gun now.
- I actually need to go
to the Book Walker website
just to refresh myself on--
- If you actually looked
at my Book Walker account
it's like old galleries.
Because most of the time
I buy it for the videos,
but I actually have bought
some like an ironically,
like 10 Dance.
I've bought all of 10 Dance.
There's only five volumes
and it's actually like a
really fucking good Yaoi.
Ironically, imagine like
a shown in levels of hype
but with ballroom dancing and Italo spicy
like it's actually pretty good.
- I mean, I'm gonna shout
out the index series
which I've actually read levels on that.
- [Conner] But love the anime.
- Yeah so if you are unsatisfied
or confused by season
three please, please read
the light novel of Book
Walker on Book Walker
because that's like one of the best arcs
in index before like pre new testaments.
But I'm not gonna get in to that.
But yeah please read the--
- New Testament?
(laughing)
(indistinct)
- I could give a good recommendation
if you're feeling depressed
maybe and wanna feel
more depressed I would say--
- Thought that was going
somewhere else there.
- No, I would say Aku no
Hana it's not a bad shout.
- That's a really good monitor.
- Exactly!
- What is it about?
- That's really good, Flowers of Evil.
Is a really good monitor.
- They have a anime of it,
but it not really an anime.
It's like kind of like--
- What happens?
- So this guy, he kind of just
slip out how everybody kind
of sucks and reality there
that's the description.
- Basically yeah.
- Is that it?
- It's literally just about
a dude who just gets himself
into a really shity situation,
that you can't get out of it.
And then he just realizes
man, humans fucking sucks.
- Essentially is like he
tries to not be normal
when he's handling the situation.
He doesn't wanna be seen as
somebody that can be described
or like is seen as like
when they're describing him
like something that can be sewn as cliche
but he's actually the most
cliche fucker out there.
(laughs)
- So humans may suck but
thank God, Book Walkers
collection of amazing manga
and light novels does it.
- You don't have to deal with humans
because you can just go on Book Walker
and forget about everything.
- Exactly!
- Also have Attack on Titan on there,
which if you want to keep up with.
- What's that I've never--
- It just a little small thing.
(indistinct)
Black Butler as well if you're wondering.
- I think I have heard of
that one actually, yeah.
(indistinct)
- If you want to ever know what
it's like to be a prostitute
in other world, JK Haru is
a sex worker, fuckers go!
Do you wanna explain that one?
- Yeah, I feel you said a lot of words
and I feel like need explaining that.
- It like the description of the title.
But literally JK HARO is a
sex worker in another world.
- How is that, is it like
inter-species reviews
but like the other way around?
- Yeah she is a prostitute.
Yeah!
- I've legitimately heard
good things about that.
From several people.
- It's actually very
well-written it's very saucy,
makes me blush when I have to read it.
- Is it like aliens?
- It for people.
- So what's like the real
hook for that series?
- Is essentially just
kind of there's a lot
of like little mini twists in there.
I'm not going to get the spoilers
cause go read it yourselves.
But essentially if you
want to know what it's like
being a sex worker and another world...
- I feel like I can't
relate to either of those.
- Yeah.
- If you try reading it, it can.
- Maybe I can relate
to being a sex worker.
- I never thought to myself,
I wanna go to another world
nor have I thought to myself
I wanna be a prostitute.
(indistinct)
- One line obviously
is I want to recommend
because it just finished
as of recently the animate
just finished and the
lineup was just finished
is Yahari Ore No.
- Are you going to recommend
to read instead of watch?
- Yeah!
- Is always Joey.
- No actually I would
recommend the animate as well,
but if you wanna get like a
full glimpse into the characters
and everything, because
that's the selling point.
- That's a light novel?
- Yeah, that's a light novel.
So it was originally a light novel series.
It just finished as of recently,
I think it has 14 volumes.
- It's a chunky boy.
- It's chunky boy, it's a
chunky boy, but I haven't read
it all yet, but I kind of
read up to like volume six
or seven around when like
season two of the anime finished
and it is really fucking good.
Like that it almost, it almost
exceeds light novel quality.
It's almost like just
a regular standard book
because the characters
are just so well-written
and it's a lot like Aku
no Hana where it's about
just how shity humans can
be and some do just trying--
- That's me!
- Fit in there!
(laughing)
It's just a really relatable
story of how one guy
is just trying to fit into society,
but he just does not
like how society runs.
He just doesn't like how
the whole social hierarchy
of high school is
constructed and everything.
And he's like nah, fuck that shit.
Like I'm not going to conform.
I'm not going to conform to the machine.
I'm going to be my own thing.
But then he realized the
difficulties of being his own thing
and how difficult it is
to, I guess trust humans
is probably the best way to say it.
- It's a really good rate
I would recommend it.
- Trust humans, this sounds so alien.
We don't trust the humans.
- Honestly like protagonist,
like Hachimon is probably one
of the most interesting protagonists
I have ever seen in an anime.
I mean, he's one of the most
iconic anime and amazing iconic
characters in light novels.
- For sure.
- Absolutely.
- He's just so completely different.
He's he's almost like a
deconstruction of a protagonist.
- Okay.
- Yeah.
So it's really interesting.
If you want something a little different
I would recommend it again.
(indistinct)
(laughing)
- I've ruined the word
different from myself every time
I hear the word different now.
- I've read a lot of the light novels,
but this one just strikes comparatively.
It does hit different
yes, so I recommend it.
And thank God you can read it on Book...
Meilyne can you read
Oregairu on Book Walker?
- [Meilyne] Oregairu?
- Yeah!
- [Meilyne] I think there's a lot of them.
- There's a lot of them,
go read on Book Walker.
I already need to just check.
- They also have the
gallery called public sex,
which is a, exactly what you think it is.
- It speaks for itself doesn't it?
- Literally just public sex, yawei!
- Honey you haven't recommended yet.
- I'm trying to.
- I got 12, so almost all of them.
You can read almost all of
the guide on Book Walker
so go check it out.
- Do I really wanna recommend
domestic girlfriend again?
- No, you don't have to do it.
- [Conner] So to tell you a
bit more about Book Walker,
Book Walker is catechol's
official bookstore
and app for digital
manga and light novels.
They currently have over
15,000 English eBooks
with new titles releasing
every single week.
- Unlike other digital eBook
platforms Book Walker was made
especially for Otakus' like you guys.
So they offer exclusive
digital bonuses items like
illustrations, wallpapers, and
short stories all the time.
So it's best to check
Book Walker constantly
if you're interested in those.
- You can read all
eBooks and manga purchase
on their website or on their dedicated app
where now they have
both vertical strolling
and horizontal scrolling.
- Ooh look--
- That's called innovation!
- Look at how sexy that is.
- Yeah, it is Book Walkers
global's 5th anniversary
celebration and to celebrate,
you can get up to 50%
coin back plus earn up
to 30,000 extra coins.
And if you know anything
about Book Worker,
you would know that's a goddamn deal.
- For those of you who don't
know coins are their in-store
currency that you get when
you purchase anything.
- Yeah, it's like a
point system basically.
- Thank you very much to Book Walker
for sponsoring this
episode, back to the video.
Knowing you personally, I
feel that a lot of your lack
of confidence stems from a certain event
you had with another internet
personality, namely Leafy.
Like I've already explained the
bear, like the overall story
from my perspective, but what
was it like for you like being
in one of his videos and
being called out by him?
- Well, obviously that
plays a large part as well.
And my lack of confidence
also, I just don't think
I'm a very confident person,
but with the Leafy thing--
- How did to all start, what
was the, like how did you,
when did, when did you make that video?
- I made the video actually,
cause you know how obviously
I used to be that predictable
kind of weedy cringe girl.
But up until I think the
first time I went to Japan
and then I came back from
Japan, I looked at myself
like, what the was wrong with me?
And that's when I made that video
kind of as like Oh my God,
like people like this exist.
- Like poking fun.
It was kind of like a satire.
- It was good though.
(laughing)
- It was way to real.
- You understood your
core audience way to well.
- Well when I first saw
that I thought he was legit.
- Yeah.
But and then like this one
creepy guy kept re uploading
it and like he kept up leading
to four Chan obviously.
And then I deleted it when I was like 17
because I was like, I
don't want to cut it.
- How long was it before you deleted it?
- About a day.
- A day!
- Like a few days maybe,
but it was not up long.
- It just like blew up straight away?
- No, and then a few years
later like I haven't been doing
YouTube in a bit I was
just still like in England.
And then I get this notification
from this girl that I knew
and like who kind of like
goes on for chance like that.
And she said, hey this
video is this video of you.
And it was me obviously it was a video
and it had about 60,000 views.
And I'm just like, initially
I was pretty like embarrassed.
I didn't feel good, like
to me it's 60,000 views
at that time--
- That's a lot!
- Was like the world.
And then I kind of like,
felt pretty shity about that.
But then not even a week
later I wake up in the middle
of the night to my phone
just constantly vibrating
with all of these messages from
people I went to high school
with, people I'd met maybe once or twice,
all on Facebook, all on
Skype, Twitter just everywhere
of like, hey you're on Leafy
video and you're pretty cringe.
- It was like at the peak of Leafy.
- This was actually his
most viewed video ever.
- Is it actually?
How many views do they have?
- Last time I checked it was 20 million,
something like that.
- Jesus Christ.
- And it sucked because I
woke up to hundreds of emails
with people telling me to kill myself.
And this lasted for months.
- Because I remember every
time, cause how the ball
kept rolling was that
every time the comments
were starting to die down,
there would another cringe compilation.
And it was the cringe compilations
that kept this going on
for so long because it
appeared in the Leafy video,
which was just like, which
just lit the fucking fire.
And then he got all the Leafy fans.
And then as soon as that,
you basically hold up in like
a bunker and just like kept
away from the internet.
And as soon as she like came out
another cringe compilation would come out.
- And then I'd be getting,
I still, even to this day,
people I know message
me like with the video,
like, hey I just saw you
in a crunch compilation.
And it kind of like
slightly make fun of me.
And obviously it doesn't
feel initially for years
of course, it was awful.
I didn't touch my phone, I'd cry a lot.
I went through a pretty bad
period, I'm not going to lie.
Like I was pretty, it was
awful and no amount of words
or any kind of emotion that
could show you now could show
you how terrible it kind of was.
- I mean just imagining, it
is just fucking horrible.
- It was terrible.
- Because I can imagine it
gets to the point where people
I knew from like my hometown,
people who were like,
didn't know about like anime and stuff.
I think that was the point when I remember
it was like really hit you that
man this has gone really far
when you're high school friends.
- That's 20 million views on one video
but on all those compilations, those ones.
It could easily be up to a
hundred million people views.
- Exactly!
Obviously talking about it
now, it doesn't feel great
but I think of course I
mean it's been so long,
I've accepted it.
And people say like, oh you're
really you've seen insults
I'll be like, dude, like who the are you?
- I think the fact that
you've managed to live
through that and still being like
I still want to stay on the internet
I think it's pretty fucking (indistinct)
I know I would immediately
leave the internet.
- I definitely almost
didn't even try with YouTube
because like with Garnt--
- I mean, I don't blame
you I think anybody
would be like, nope never going on to me.
- It took a lot of convincing to try
and get Sidney back on the internet.
And it was something
where I knew that Sydney
had a personality that could
like succeed on YouTube,
it was just trying to convince
her that, hey just ignore all
these comments that you've
been hearing over the past.
- Fuck the haters.
- Yeah fuck the haters.
- Fuck the haters, fuck the hate comments
and just be you cause one
thing I can appreciate about
Sydney is that she doesn't know
how to be anyone but herself.
Like what you see is what you will get.
So like that can also backfire sometimes.
(laughing)
Where people will think,
where the cringe compilations
and stuff like that.
But you know you're where you are now.
And I think you're doing
pretty fucking well.
- If there's one thing I can say,
you're a personality Sydney.
- You're definitely a personality.
- You're 100% a personality.
- Congrats for being a personality.
- You made it.
- I felt so bad cause I remember like,
I don't know if you remember
this but I didn't know you,
but I knew you cause a voice acting.
Do you remember this?
I feel so bad about this,
but now I don't give a shit.
Cause I know you so I don't care.
So I knew Sydney from voice acting.
And so when I met Sydney,
when I first saw her in person
I was like oh shit it's her.
(laughing)
- You were like hey!
(indistinct)
- And that was the reaction
that Sydney was so scared of.
Because there'd be so many
times we'd be walking around
and she'd just see like
a person like turn around
and she's like, and Sydney
would be like, he knows.
We need to leave right
now, oh God, oh God.
- Not the greatest, but
I'm like oh I'm a celebrity
But more of like oh shit.
- I need the other pair of sunglasses.
(laughing)
- I met Sydney and then I
realized that it was her.
And I asked her, I was like Sydney
are you like the cringe girl?
I said that--
- You said that?
- Remember looking down and I'm like,
I'm never gonna talk to this guy.
(laughing)
Fuck this guy.
- She was like I have no idea
what compelled me to ask you.
I think like, as I was
talking to you it just came
to my head and I was like say it Conner,
say it, fucking say it.
I don't know why, I would
never do that normally.
I'd normally go home and fucking analyze.
Immense, you know but I
asked you and then I remember
when you told the story the first time
about how hard it was,
I was like, oh shit.
- Talks about it and be like
I don't know him well enough
to tell him to stop. (laughs)
I don't mind now obviously but back then,
she was like (gasping).
- It's weird for me because
I found out about the whole
Leafy thing after I met you.
So when I first met you all I
knew you was Garnt's partner.
So it was really like
weird hearing that story
like afterwards cause I
don't know if you told
me or someone else told me.
I think maybe you told me about it.
- I think it was me first.
- Probably when we first met.
- Hi I'm the cringe girl.
(laughing)
- I think I've got you drunk enough
by the way I was in a Leafy video.
(laughing)
- I think something came
up and you were like
do you do stuff online?
I'm like, maybe you have seen
me, (laughs) at that time.
- Maybe it's because I wasn't on YouTube
as much at the time.
I was on YouTube, but
I wasn't going around
watching other YouTubers at the time.
- I cripplingly addicted to YouTube.
- And also like at that point as well,
I hadn't been on four canning years.
So I didn't know what the fuck
was happening over there as well.
So then when I saw that video,
after you told me about
it I was like, oh, okay
this is the video that
people talking about.
- But I think it was really weird.
I don't know if I'm
maybe the first. (laughs)
- I think you actually were.
Like you're the only person
who's just like didn't know.
- If it's any consolation I
don't think it was that bad.
- Thank you!
- I don't think it was that bad either.
- I think it was pretty obvious
to me, but I guess it was.
- I think it just
because it's anime people
like animates, cringe.
So that's why.
- Especially back then as well.
- Yeah.
- Like when we were like, we
abuse where the face of like,
(indistinct)
- When you see videos of like,
cause sometimes I don't
know why I love doing this.
I just like search like 2008
conventions or 2010 conventions
and just watch blogs from
people with like a hundred views
because you get some of the
best shit from doing that.
'Cause there's like so
much in drama between
these friends, like, like
Cody left on day two.
(laughing)
Because he refused to
share the bed with me.
And it's like, there'll be like
a hundred of you've locked.
(indistinct)
- Shane shut in the bed,
couldn't fucking believe it.
- It'll be one.
I remember this one
time cause when I went,
I guess at a convention like India,
some Indian convention, not
any popcorn, another one.
And this convention been
going on for a while.
So I was going back every single year
and finding blogs of it.
And then there was this
one guy from like 2010
and he opens up the blog
with, yeah so Cody's not here.
You guys know why and
just doesn't explain why.
(laughing)
And for some reason it's so funny.
- I killed him, I
straight up murdered him.
- Because like 2000 like
mid 2000 conventions
I remember it just seemed
like you're walking
into another world.
The rules of like, I
remember when just the rules
of normal society did not
apply to anime conventions.
- I tried so hard.
- I usually hate watching
cringe compilation videos.
Cause I personally can't stand them,
I always find them funny.
But the one types of cringe
compilations, I fucking love
is like the mid 2000,
like marriage proposal.
(mumbling)
Fucking best, it's like watching
it's always outside of
the convention center.
And there's a crowd of people.
- All the same course players?
- It's usually like Narahino somebody--
- Always Narahino.
- Its always Narahino.
I dunno what it is.
- I think one of my
favorite videos on YouTube
of all time is this video
called 2001: An Anime Odyssey.
I remember showing it to them at Christmas
and it's just basically a highlight reel
of this very old anime documentary
that follows like these--
- So good!
- Follows these people at
certain anime conventions.
And like this was before the mid 2000s.
This is like the late 90s and
Oh my God some of the stuff
that was going on there was just--
- What was the name of the dude?
- Johnny Otaku!
- Johnny Otaku, my man.
- The legend!
- Like he was like, yeah I'm
going to be a Funimation.
(laughing)
(indistinct)
- I actually searched
his, searched up his story
after I saw that video.
- Should you explain Johnny Otaku
to people who might not know.
- Johnny Otaku is one of
the most like, like one
of the creepiest kind of
self-confidence anime fans.
You could like ever see.
- He is one of the most
infamous anime fan.
- The most infamous.
- The kind of guy who
brings you to a convention
and is like, oh I know everyone here.
(indistinct)
- He is like, not even
the guests, but he's like
I know the staff.
- Yeah.
- I remember in the documentary
he was like running his own radio show.
That was like an anime radio show.
And he was trying to be a voice actor
that he said, he was saying,
he was an aspiring voice actor.
Which you know, going off
tangent, I don't know why people
use the word aspiring.
(laughing)
(indistinct)
Like when I go on a Twitter
profile and I see the word
aspiring and I'm like, come
on dude, you can do better.
- Aspiring voice actor just
means I own a Yeti snowball.
That's all I mean.
- Just say you're a voice
actor or just don't put
it in, just like one
or the other, you know?
But yeah, he wasn't aspiring voice actor.
And I searched up his
story after I saw the video
and I saw like this Funimation
panel where they were talking
about this person called like
John or Johnny or something
that tried so hard to get an
audition that they literally
had to ban him from
the Funimation offices.
Cause he was like stalking
employees and all the shit.
And then I kind of just
connected the dots.
I was like, wait a minute
there's this guy called Johnny
in this one video who like really aspired
to be like Vic Mignogna and
then there's this another story
by Funimation employees who's
talking about this guy called
Johnny stalking Funimation
employees at their offices.
And I'm like, ooh that's yikes.
- Can I just say, can we get Johnny Otaku?
- Oh my God!
- That would be fucking legendary.
Johnny if you're watching
this, please come to Japan.
I know you love this country,
just come here we'll
put you on the podcast.
- Yeah.
- I wanna hear the story.
- I implore the viewers at home.
Just type in any anime convention
and type in like 2010 to 15 it's so funny.
- Watch 2001: An Anime Odyssey
it's a 30 minute video.
But my God it's--
- It's so good!
- You'll have the time of your life.
Going back to you, Sydney.
Going back to your Japan,
the Japan trip I would say
that completely ruined your perception
of anime and weaves in general.
So do you want to explain
like why that happened or what happened?
- Were you the stereotypical weep
before everything before was better.
Describe yourself, describe
what you were like before
and describe what happened in the squad.
- In the beginning was like
I had a Japanese foreign
exchange student cause I was
like, oh, Japanese people.
(indistinct)
(laughing)
- My nuts just went inside.
- I've definitely up
until I think I met her.
I calmed down a lot.
I'm like, she's pretty normal.
(laughing)
And then she let me stay
at her house in Japan
after she went back home after a year.
- How old were you?
- I was 17.
So I went to her house and
then I kind of just went
everywhere in Tokyo.
That was like anything and the whole time,
like I loved the trip.
Don't get me wrong, but do
I think that it was anime,
you know, heaven here.
Like do I think like--
- What was your image of
Japan before coming here?
- I thought I'd come here
and that'd be like an instant
like everyone be like,
oh cool blonde girl.
(laughing)
Just like do I need internet,
you wanna be an idol in Japan.
Just take over the country.
- Reminder she says she
had no self-confidence.
You heard that.
(laughing)
- Once like I grew up and
realize like, man shit!
- Life really hits you like a truck.
- And then like once I
grew up, I'm like shit
how come I left your Japan and
I wasn't like prime minister?
(laughing)
- That's like every white
guy in a foreign country.
- I was like what if I'm not so good?
And then I made like I started reflecting.
Yeah, definitely just on everything.
And I'm like, fuck anime lied to me.
- This is a normal country!
- And then just like local off.
- Like you, I remember you
were telling me stories about
how you were cost played in
Akihabara and stuff like that.
- Because like when I
went to Japan, it was 2012
and about I think a year prior or a year
and a half prior "Anohana" finished.
And we went to, and I really
love Anohana like goner.
So I went to the village for Chichipu
which is where I was based off of.
And since I was like the
blonde blue eyed girl
they were like, oh Menma!
So they made me like dress
up as Menma for a picture.
- Who made you dress up like Menma?
- We went to the place that was like,
cause they were having
a festival for Anohana.
And then there was like a
street completely dedicated
towards like looking like the
anime like they had a secret
base and everything.
And so we went to the store,
I think where they were like
beginning to run everything.
And then people were just
like, they're like, oh shit.
Like we need somebody to like
cosplay to gain more people
to want to come over.
And then, so they just like
they asked me Japanese--
- Find a white girl.
'Cause I think she's meant
to be white in the anime
if I remember like they
were, where is Menma?
- I don't get into that.
- I think she's supposed to be Japanese.
(laughing)
- You know anime being anime
is like let's just make them not Japanese.
- They made me wear Menma costume like--
- A bright dress.
- Yeah.
And I don't think I've
ever felt so wanted.
(laughing)
The Japanese people where
like, I just remember
the flashing light I couldn't see.
They're just like telling me to pose
and I was just like shit. (giggles)
I don't know I'm just like
blonde hair, blue eyed
and wearing a Menma dress
and I've never felt so loved.
(indistinct)
- You got too much love
or you didn't get any.
(laughing)
Didn't didn't you get
accused of being racist.
- Oh no, you're gonna go down there?
- Why not, why not?
- Let's just jump right into it.
- So, okay when I was studying in England
I quickly had to pick a
thing I wanted to major
in and I just picked Japanese, all right.
I'll say it, I majored in Japanese.
- Of course, I believe.
- Oh fuck!
So I went to a university in London
and God I really hope
he doesn't watch this.
Oh, so okay.
(laughing)
So I had a Japanese professor
and we'd obviously write
essays as you do in university.
And he let us pick the genre
like what we want to write about exactly.
And I picked about like
kind of Japan's fascination
with Westerners and
like kind of their looks
it kind of like meet you,
like stuff like that.
And so I felt really good about it.
Like I thought it was
the best I ever wrote.
Garnt read it is like shit!
- I actually thought it was a good essay.
- And then I was like so excited,
I'm like this is the best.
And I'd never been so hyped for a grade.
(laughing)
(indistinct)
- I can't wait to get that fucking A.
- But then I get my grades
back two weeks later
and it's a zero out of a
hundred and I'm just like,
what the fuck?
And so I messaged him like
why did I get a zero for this?
He was like, because it was like
he never explicitly said
racist, but he's like
you were very insensitive
to Japanese people.
And it's just like just a lot of stuff.
And I remember just like crying
because I'm like, oh my God.
This is actually racist!
(laughing)
- So was your professor
like full Japanese?
- Yeah he was full, he literally came
like he was older Japanese
man who came to like teach
Japanese culture in the university.
And yeah!
- Maybe you just gave him
a pill he couldn't swallow.
- Yeah!
- Like shit she called me out.
(indistinct)
(laughing)
- When you told me that I'm
like, but like every single sign
near your houses like white people.
- Yeah.
- It's always white people.
- The gym I don't see a
single Asian (indistinct)
It's always gripped white dudes.
- The longer I live here
the more I'm like, man
I shouldn't got a fucking zero.
(laughing)
- A hundreds!
- Like a thousands.
- 'Cause I remember you go back the grade
and you're like I had to
convince you for the week
that you just weren't racist.
- Garnt am I racist?
- Maybe I'm racist, maybe I am like you.
- You're like fucking Martin
Luther, it's just like,
I'm just dropping these truth bombs,
just can't handle it.
- I was like convinced I was racist.
- Is that how it works.
- Isn't it, like shit what
if I have internal racism?
And I never even knew.
But yeah, I almost failed the
university because of that.
- Wow!
- He made me rewrite it and he
actually gave me good points
for it, I had to write about
it I had read memoirs--
- Did you drop out anyway?
- I did.
(laughing)
I wanted that credit.
So yeah, that was--
- You could argue that the professor
was being racist to you.
- Shit!
- That's a resource
excuse I have ever heard.
- Reverse uno card. (laughs)
Excuse me sir I believe you
are the racist one here.
- Coming at me.
- That's just 2020 then.
(laughing)
- Oh my God.
- So I got to ask what was
like the anime community
like when you were in
like your full weep phase
because you--
- Full of racism.
- You like fully embraced it, right?
Like how was anime conventions
and everything for you?
- Yeah, I never went an anime
convention until like 2017.
My first anime convention was like 20, 20
like 2012 or something that.
- Still early.
- I hadn't even started
YouTube at that point.
- Wait, what year was the
first anime convention
you went to?
- 2009.
- Oh my God!
- It was anime Milwaukee and
anime Milwaukee hit me up bro.
No, it's anime Milwaukee and
I remember cause obviously
I was a full week and
everyone's like glamp.
I'm like, Oh my God, that's so original.
- Glamp, oh my God!
- Got shivers down my
spine here right now.
- I just lost the game and I'm
like, that's the most clever
shit I have ever had.
(laughing)
- Wait, what is glamping?
- Glamping is when you,
do you wanna explain it?
- You don't know what
glamping is? (laughs)
- Is that the thing where
you jump on something?
- Yeah is like glamp...
- Is like you come up to a random person
and you literally just give him a hug.
- And sometimes it's
like the most aggressive
hug you can get.
- Yeah, it hurts sometimes.
- It's like a rugby tackle,
that's what's it's like.
- Why is like so many
things in anime conventions
just don't sound right to me.
- I didn't know you could be assaulted
by a hug until I experienced the glamp.
I'm just like, oh that felt dirty.
What the hell is that?
- When was the last time you showered.
- Dude what do you think of free hugs?
I can't fucking stand the free hugs.
I'm like, why would I want
to hug a sweaty stranger?
That's the last thing I ever want to do?
- I actually like before the
whole rona, nothing happened.
Like I remember going to
Shibuya and almost every time
there's like--
- They have free hugs.
- There is a free free hug
sign, I'm like who does this?
It's 2019, who does this?
- It's like a viewer, who's
like, I want to hug him.
Like I got you, but if it's
like just someone standing
there whose been hugged by
like a 100 different people,
I'm like damn I don't want
your hugs. (indistinct)
Get away from me.
- Get off of me.
But is like you don't know
what they want from you.
Like, do you want to
feel my tender breasts
on your sweaty showerless body.
- Exactly, it just
looks really rapy to me.
- I'm in like the one meter
radius and I can smell
the acts I can smell
it, I don't need this.
- I can feel it in my pores.
- No I didn't, even when I was younger
I just thought the shit was stupid.
Like, I don't know maybe some
are British, I don't know.
- I dunno like,--
(indistinct)
I mean, I just like my
personal space (laughing)
go into anime conventions back in the day
just seemed like everyone
looked for an excuse
just to violate your personal
space as much as possible.
And I remember like Yaoi Paddles
that entire fucking face.
(indistinct)
- I've watched a number of
videos on the Yaoi Paddle.
(indistinct)
But I watched that I was like I'm so glad
I wasn't at conventions during that time.
- Yeah.
- What I heard about
like, people just hit you.
(laughing)
No one had a problem with this.
- That's just a physical
assault, extra steps.
(laughing)
- Physical assault with attitude.
- It's like, if I just put the word
like hentai on a belt and
we're like it's an hentai belt.
(laughing)
(indistinct)
- Father, please.
- I saw and what I heard
about the Yaoi Paddle,
I heard stories about it's
this is going to look amazing.
- This thing everyone's hitting it.
It must be amazing if
everyone just letting it fly.
I see it and it's just like burned in Yaoi
like serif font in to a panel.
And I'm like, this is what
everyone let each other hit them.
- There was like, I've seen
pictures of like old conventions
whether it was selling it at--
- Yeah, they sell them.
- And I'm like, what is
this fucking hunger games?
Like, it's just like (indistinct)
- It just proves that they
will literally buying anything
at the anime convention.
If you just put the words, Yaoi on it.
- Yeah.
- It's a fucking the wooden
paddle, there is nothing.
And there was literally
nothing special about this.
Why were people buying this?
- Material costs like
10 cents in that thing.
You selling it for like five bucks.
- There's so much shit
in anime conventions,
like who's buying this.
Like you know, oh my God!
- I don't know I feel
like it's just evolved--
- I think I'm British--
- Now if you wanna sell
something in an anime convention
spit a fucking hi girl face on it.
That shit will sell like hotcakes.
- I remember, I would see people go around
with like these steins,
like the metal steins.
I'm like, why is everyone holding a stein?
- What the fuck is a stein?
- Really big, like German mug.
And there was someone like
the vendors was just selling
like weird kind of concoctions.
And I was like why?
Why are you carrying around
a metal ass jug all day
that you can refill?
You can just drink some
fucking water out of it.
I don't wanna hold a
fucking glass all day.
Yeah this thing was huge.
And I'm just like, what's
wrong with anime fans?
(laughing)
They buy anything that
is put infront of them.
It's a deal though.
- Maybe if you looked
closely at the stein--
(indistinct)
- It's the Yaoi stein.
- My parents just fucking,
they just told me everything
that you don't need is a scam Conner.
Like 7Up, you don't need that.
You got water, it's a scam.
7Up is scam.
- 7Up is pretty bombed, though.
I prefer 7Up over Sprite.
- Yeah.
(indistinct)
- McDonald's Sprite.
- McDonald's Sprite?
- McDonald's Sprite is the best.
- What's the difference between
it and a regular Sprite?
- Oh my God, have you ever had McDonald's,
American McDonald's Sprite.
- Why would I walk into
a McDonald's in America?
(laughing)
- That is true, that is true.
- When I used to work in a McDonald's
cause it's like a syrup, right?
So we had to like connect it,
one time I got like the
Coke syrup on my hands
and I was like...
(laughing)
And it was like, (groans)
like the sweeter.
Imagine that's what 15 old me thought
doing a line of Coke was like.
Shit was so sweet and juicy.
Oh my God it was amazing.
- Circulent!
- Circulent and it was amazing.
That was beautiful and that
was the only good thing
to have happened with him.
- Did you guys ever see the
Yaoi guy at like the first,
some of the first conventions you went to?
- Yaoi guy?
- I don't know, there was this guy, right.
I don't know how he got
all around the world
but he'd go around to some
of the biggest conventions
and you'd know it was the Yaoi guy.
Cause there would be this one
booth that would be setting
like Yaoi and the Dinshis
and then there would just be
this guy that would just keep
shouting out, Yaoi get you Yaoi!
- Oh my God yes!
- Yes I've met him.
- You've met him?
- I've met him, he was at
a convention in Finland.
- Yeah.
- I like, I think I saw you
in America, like last month.
Why are you here?
- I saw him at like an ACN
convention and then I saw
him again and like MCM two months later.
I dunno how he just like,
he would always shout this out.
And I remember--
- Telling me that Mr.Yaoi
is also Mr. World.
(laughing)
(indistinct)
- I remember because of how aggressively
he would fucking sell Yaoi to girls.
Girls would come up and he
goes, yo girl what do you want?
What Yaoi did you want?
This girl is buying gay porn everyone.
She's buying Yaoi!
Hi what Yaoi do you want,
and then the girls would come up
and then would there be
a different guy selling
the to banshees at the same booth.
And it would be like this
indiscreet drug dealer
being like, yo, yo, yo
boy, what do you want?
Like, no one has to see,
I'll fucking bag it up.
No one has to see it will be
coming in a the paper bag.
- Penetration stuff.
(laughing)
- Slip it on.
- I dunno like I think
he's got gotten bound
or something now because
I haven't seen him.
- That would annoyed the fuck out of me.
- Yeah, cause thinking back,
I'm like, that probably
wasn't cool for like any girl
who just wanted to buy
something, some Yaoi.
- Like some next level sexual assault.
(laughing)
It's like the most like
big brain sexual assault.
It's like I'm not actually
assaulting you sexually,
but I kind of am by words.
- Yeah.
- I love anime conventions
but I just feel like
I'm like out of my league man.
I'm like, I get that and I'm
like, I love the atmosphere,
but sometimes you just see weird shit
and you're like, all right,
okay I'm gonna head out.
- I dunno what it is when
I hear about you go to AIX
or something and you hear about
a group of guys who have met
on discord and like I'm like
rent out an Airbnb together
for some reason 90% of
the time that just never
ends up well. (laughs)
- Well, I did that and it went horrible.
- I hear that and I'm just
like that's how murders happen.
- Thing I thought was like, right listen
this hotel is expensive.
I don't care who is gonna be in this room.
I need you to just fill it
and get this price down.
(indistinct)
I'm broke as fuck.
I need this hotel to cost
$100 for this whole thing
or I'm out.
- You kind of like take the
area of like the hotel room
and you're like how
many times can I divide
this by human body?
So, okay that's how
many bodies is sleeping
in this room right.
- This is where you gotta become the host?
If you're the host no one can argue
whether you get like the bed.
It's like well I arranged
it, what are you gonna do?
It's in my name, what do you
mean make me take the floor.
You wouldn't dare.
(laughing)
- This episode is sponsored by Honey.
- These days It feels like online shopping
is the only shopping that we do.
- That's true, that's true Garnt.
- I never go outside to shop anymore
and that's where Honey comes in.
- It's the free browser extension
that scours the internet
for promo codes and automatically applies
the best one available at the checkout.
I am reading a script.
- So gentlemen, do you
love spending money?
- I love spending money,
but you know what?
Do you know what I love
more than spending money?
- Tell me!
- Getting free money.
- Oh my God, I love free money.
Gentlemen, here's how it works.
You get Honey on your computer
for free, in two easy clicks.
By going to joinhoney.com/trashtaste.
Then when you're checking out
on one of it's over 30,000
supported sites, that's a loss.
That's a loss
- That's a big number.
- That's a lot of damage.
- That's a lot of shop sites.
Well, Honey pops up and all you
have to do is click apply coupons.
That's it, you saved money.
- And you just wait a few seconds
and it'll apply all the
coupons automatically.
You do zero effort and
for nothing for free
you gain free money or
you save free money.
- I fucking love free money,
I love the free money.
- Who doesn't love free money.
- I love pizza.
(laughing)
- I also love pizza and Honey saved me
personally tons of money on pizza.
And I know as you guys know,
pizza is pretty fucking (mumbles).
- I'll complete your
sentence, pizza is (mumbles)
(laughing)
- Pizza is expensive and I saved
a lot of money off of pizza.
- How much money did you save Joey?
- I'd say at least 10, 20
bucks, at least a minimum.
- I use Honey on a lot of clothing store
and recently I did save
about like 30 bucks on them.
- Oh sure--
- I never put honey on pizza
but I definitely use Honey for pizza.
The sponsor for today's video.
(laughing)
- Joking aside, I've actually
used it and it's good
by the way, I've saved like 10 bucks
on stuff before just saying.
- And that's Honey,
it's simple, it's free,
it's easy to use, what
are you waiting for?
Go install it today.
- Honey has found over 17 million members
over $ two billion in savings.
That's so about the same amount
as Garnt's spend on Gacha.
- Wow!
(laughing)
Mr Bees please, please sponsor me.
I need help with my Gacha.
- [Joey] Not only that, but Honey supports
all kinds of retailers
from tech and gaming sites
to fashion brands to even food delivery.
Yes, including pizza.
- Oh my God.
- Joinhoney.com/trashtastes link
is in the description below.
- That's joinhoney.com/trashtaste.
- Thank you to honey
sponsor of today's episode.
- Back to the video.
- Do you guys feel as
though have like at least
that one like anime convention story
that you share with people though?
Cause like, yeah--
- Have like a million.
- Yeah, I mean like but that
one that just sticks out
to you just like you meet
somebody or I should I guess
specify that one convention story
where somebody was the
biggest fucking asshole.
Yeah, because we have one.
- Mine just go out the window, I swear.
- We should probably tell this one
when we're both on this podcast.
Because I remember the
one guy that ever stood
out to both of us.
I've told this story on Sydney's channel
before but it was the very
first time me and Sidney
had met in person and like
probably started dating.
So anyone who's been in a
long distance relationship
will know how difficult that is.
Like when you don't get to
see your partner very often.
So you have to like treasure every moment
that you get to be with your partner.
Now this was the very
first time me and Sydney
had met in person and it was 2014 ACM.
And on the last day we
had to say our goodbyes.
And obviously it was a very, very--
- I have heard the story.
- A very, very--
- I think I know this one.
- It was a very, very tearful goodbye.
Cause obviously at the time we didn't know
when we would next get to see each other.
So Sydney was in my arms
and she was like crying.
It was like, it wasn't like a subtle cry.
It was a proper cry.
- Like an ugly cry.
- It was like makeup
spewed all over your face,
kind of crying.
- Like he is going to war man.
(laughing)
- I'm like comforting her
and as we're just like
hugging together I just hear
it in the corner of my ear, Gigguk!
(laughing)
And now I was just like, (exhaling deeply)
- I love this story so much.
I started being just
like, (exhaling deeply)
Hi!
And there this guy standing
at me and he had like,
the surprise faced and
you know, I was trying
to like signal, like look at Sydney.
Look at Sydney, look Sydney.
Like just give us a moment
because this is my very
first convention in America.
And like probably my very
first convention as a YouTuber.
So I wasn't used to getting recognized,
if this happened now I'd be like,
dude can you give us a moment?
But back then, I did not
know how to deal with it.
- You didn't know how to say, hold on.
- Yeah, I didn't have
to say no, basically.
So he was like, can I take a picture?
And I'm just like, in the inside
I was is this guy serious?
Is this guy fucking serious right now?
(laughing)
I'm like, okay, sure.
- And so we separate, right?
- Yeah we separate.
- I go to the side and he comes to me--
- Wait, wait, wait, wait,
wait, I got this, I got this.
I got this, I got this.
So he tries taking some pictures, right.
And he does the thing
where the first selfie
he's not happy with.
So he's just like, let me try that again.
Okay, okay now.
- You get three and I'm like fuck off.
- And he tries a third time
and he's still not happy.
And then he looks over to
Sydney makeup all over her face,
tears down her fucking
face, all over her cheeks.
And I'm just like, don't do it.
Don't fucking do it, don't fucking do it.
Can you take a picture for us please?
(laughing)
- I'm still crying and I'm like sure.
'Cause I didn't know what
to do, then I did it.
(laughing)
- He has the gut to ask Sydney
to take a picture for us.
- I did it though.
- I went from like really,
really sad that I'm not going
to see Sydney for a while to
just like confused, angry.
To be like is this guy for real?
Is he for real?
How are you feeling in that?
- I was pretty pissed, I
was angry, but I was like,
because I thought maybe
like, is this normal.
(laughing)
- Yes!
- He's like a big star.
I should know, I should know
better and just leave it.
- At least he wasn't like,
hey Sydney do you want
to be in the photo with us?
(laughing)
That would have been (indistinct).
- Clean yourself up and get in the photo.
(laughing)
- Bathroom is over there.
- Spill some water and come back.
- Speaking of bathroom I remember,
this isn't pretty much the story
but that was the worst time
someone asked me for a photo.
I was queuing up to take
a shit, I kid you not.
I'm taking a shit and the guy...
So you've got like line
cause the fucking toilet
is tiny in the anime convention center.
And the guy's having a piss on the cubicle
and another cubicle, the urinal
and I'm just on my phone.
He turns around, he's like, CDawg!
Yo what's up,
thinking that like that's
it cause we're a toilet.
Can I take a photo?
I'm like, you didn't even wash your hands.
Don't come near me, still
zipping up his pants.
No, we can't take a picture right now.
I'm about to take a shit, in the toilet.
You're pissing at the
same time it's filled.
And I feel like I'm the
asshole because now everyone's
looking at us and I'm like,
okay are you kidding me, dude?
- I've had a similar thing,
but I was actually at the urinal.
- No!
- Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
- Dick in hand?
- Yeah dick in hand.
- I've been there.
- And the dude directly next
to me was like, yo, Joey, what's up?
(laughing)
- And I'm like, can you not
see I have my penis in my hand?
- My stream would instant
stop at that moment.
- I think mine actually got faster
because I'm pretty sure this
guy is about to ask a photo.
I'm not about to get a photo taken,
as I have my dick in my hand.
(groaning)
- I had to react to
that because I remember
the he exact same thing happened to me
when I was in the urinal.
And it's the case where
there are like five
urinals in a row.
And I was in at the end and
I knew something was wrong
when a guy chooses the
one right next to me.
And I'm just like, here we go.
Here we fucking go!
(indistinct)
And I'm like, why are you?
Like my first instinct
is why are you standing
into the urinal next to me?
If you're not a gay there's an unwritten
etiquette to like toilets.
Where if the urinal next to you is free
and there's more urinal other
than one next use free--
- Basic instinct.
- You don't go to the one next
to the person already pissing.
- You don't wanna be that creep who--
That's basic urinal etiquette.
- You don't wanna be
that creep who's like,
I don't wanna look at his penis.
(laughing)
(indistinct)
- So I finished my business
and for some reason
he asked for a handshake.
I'm like, can you at least let
me wash my hands first man.
- I wanna touch the dick hand.
- For sure that's how coronavirus started.
(laughing)
- What was your most like
weird or strange convention
experience before you were a YouTuber?
Before you met Garnt, any weird stories?
- For example like the first convention?
- I would say like,
actually it was probably
I was doing like, say voice acting online.
I wasn't like massive at that point.
I was a senior in high
school and I actually worked
at the Maid Cafe at Milwaukee.
- Of course you did.
(laughing)
You didn't even need to tell me.
I just assumed.
- Oh my God I really hope
this guy doesn't watch us.
So I was just kinda of we
had 10 minutes off right.
so I was gonna get some
water or something.
And this guy is just like, wow
are you working at the Maid Cafe?
And I like had my maid apron,
we all had the same uniform.
- So he had no shit. (laughs)
- Yeah and he's like, okay.
And I'm like, okay and
I was on the escalator
and then he turned away
and then I turned away.
And then when we were
closing up for the night
this guy comes up and he
hands me like this dollar
that he origami it into a shirt.
And I'm like, do you think
this is a really cool thing?
And he's like, you can keep that dollar.
- You're frothing at this.
(laughing)
(indistinct)
- Frothing at the loins like
shit he gave me a dollar.
- And then, so I was
just sitting down waiting
for like to get my parents started
waiting for the night to end
and then he just sat down
and then he just didn't say anything.
And then 20 minutes goes by and I'm like
I'm gonna to go on the
back and I stayed there
for two hours and he
still is there waiting.
And so I actually had the manager
go out and yell at him
to get out and I feel
bad cause he's actually really shocked.
He thought I was genuine
could come in and be like,
when's our date?
I guess I felt like the
most creepiest thing like
that sounds--
- Sounds like kind a rapey.
- But it was definitely
something I look back
and I'm like I kinda feel
bad, but another way probably
could have been a bit better about it.
- I swear like I dunno what
it is about anime conventions.
that just turns anime
fans into just monkeys.
- I don't know I think it's just a lack,
like a lot of young people
and a lot of old people
who lack social skills.
- Yeah.
- Not to be mean, but I
think a lot of people who go
through it, there's a good train of people
who go out and make it mentions
who don't really like, you know?
They don't really
socialize too much outside
of maybe playing games online.
And I don't know I feel like--
- I think there's a lot
of them who just assume
that because you liked
the same thing as me.
- Yeah!
- I can do anything with you.
You're okay with it.
- Yeah I'm definitely
glad that I don't know
that when I was younger, I
didn't interact with people.
Cause I feel like I would've been weird.
- I'm kind of glad I didn't
go to anime conventions
that early as well, because
seeing how many stuff is coming
out about the smash community and stuff,
I can only imagine what happened--
(indistinct)
- I can easily get based on
what I've seen in private
like people do in anime conventions
now I can only imagine--
- I'm also surprise the smash
convention was called out
before the anime convention scene.
Because I'm sure there's horrible stories
that go behind the scene.
- I think the problem
with anime conventions
a lot of the time it's
not like the celebrities,
the organizers sometimes--
- Yeah!
- Speculating.
- I mean there are
stories of that as well.
- And it's kind of hard to...
it sucks but cancel someone
who no one cares about.
- Yeah.
- You know what I mean.
Like when you counsel like
a community like smash
you've got like these big names, right.
And when you bring it
out it's like I cared
about that person.
But dude the event organizer
of ex-con in your areas of rapist.
- Like who?
- Who is that?
(indistinct)
It's bad, I mean I not try
to make light of any of that.
I mean, it's pretty fucked up
but I mean that's kind
of how it is, right?
It's unfortunate.
I dunno it's a depressing
topic, obviously that people
don't like talking about it.
It's not that funny.
- Let's change the subject.
But okay I wanna know right
having known how you've done
YouTube for how long would you say now?
- Since the beginning of YouTube.
- Since the beginning, okay but as a job.
- Full-time job.
- As a full-time YouTuber?
- I would say in a little
over a year and a half, two.
- Year and a half, two years.
Okay, so okay cause I always
ask people who like kind
of come into the whole
full-time YouTube thing
like as of recently, right.
Because like being a full-time
YouTuber now is completely
different to like being full-time lets say
like when Garnt became full-time, right?
- Yeah.
- So like, as someone who's
been there from the beginning
of YouTube how would you
say it's like changed
as a full-time thing as
opposed to like just doing
it as a hobby?
- I think definitely
like it's more profitable
now obviously back then in the beginning,
I mean it's not like, I'm not saying
like you're rolling in it by any means.
Like Garnt said none of
my videos are (indistinct)
(laughing)
I can't really complain about that.
- Tell me the video have you reviewed
the pussy of the round
table, it wasn't monetized.
- Are you saying this episode...
Are you saying the sponsors, yes.
- If not for Patreon and sponsors
you just wouldn't have a job.
- But you're getting out there though
and that's like the important thing, yeah.
And then if you get like,
if people will watch
you then people are gonna be like shit
let's get this bitch to
advertise our fucking shit.
And then definitely it's like
back in the monetary days
when YouTube wasn't so pissy.
- YouTube was bound to happen though.
- Yeah it was bound of course--
- Everyone knew it was gonna happen.
- Somebody like me shouldn't
be monetized on that.
- I wonder cause like back
then I always think for me
like YouTube was as much
of like a social thing
for me as much as I
dream making the videos
it was more about like what...
Cause it was a single voice acting for me.
The major reason I kept doing
voice acting and I liked
it so much is that it
was like how I socialized
with those people.
- Yeah.
- And I almost felt like YouTube
was an extension of that.
Half the time, which is
why, you know when we said
in ages ago where I was like
they were only making videos
for each other, et cetera, et cetera.
Because I'm remember when I did it.
Like when you first start,
you kind of do make videos
in a sense for your peers
and for like to impress one.
Cause it's a very social
thing when you're smaller
cause there's no pressure, right?
It's like, I just wanna make videos.
My mate made a really cool video.
I wanna make a cool video to like--
- You're just dicking around with it.
- Right, right and half the
funny like what I thought
was funny at the time,
probably not funny at all.
Stuff I made was cause I'm like, dude
my friends are gonna love this off.
That's why I made it half the time.
And I feel like that aspect
pretty much goes instantly
when you start doing it full time.
You still do make friends obviously,
we're all reaching your friends
but the aspect of making
videos for like a social
purpose completely goes.
- Yeah.
- I find it.
- I mean, I'd still say
I do kind of make videos
for social purposes cause it's still--
- Technically 'cause you're talking about
current topics a lot.
- Yeah I mean, and there's
also like when we talk about
YouTube, I see YouTube now
as like I just make YouTube
for like a general audience
not just like an anime watching audience.
So like there are a lot
of other YouTubers out
there who have to do things
that are like have nothing
to do with anime but I
still respect their content.
Like it's the best fucking feeling.
When you meet a guy, a guy
or a girl who has nothing
to do with your community and
you find out that they watch
your content and you're like--
- I love your stuff.
- You love my stuff?
- Yeah.
- I love your stuff too.
- Everybody claps.
- Could we just become best friends?
- That is your best
moment 'cause you're like,
we're gonna hang out, right?
Yeah we're.
- We're gonna hang out.
We're not gonna make a video,
we're just gonna hang out.
- We just gonna just get a chill.
(laughs)
- You know, you found a
good new YouTuber friend
when you meet for the first
time and the word collab
isn't said for the first
time five meetings.
- Like you don't even take a selfie deal.
You just hang out.
- Just hang out.
- You just enjoy each other like essence.
- The worst, the biggest
thing I hate is when someone
is like, hey let's collab.
And I'm like, all right,
what'd you have in mind?
I don't know just wanna collab.
And I'm like can you come with
like an idea or something?
I don't wanna do the
work if it's your collab.
I can't stand it, like let's just collab.
Let's just do it.
Like what, what do you want to do?
Tell me what you wanna do?
- Because it's so easy to do a collab.
- I can't think of my own
videos what makes you think
I'm gonna help you with yours?
- Exactly.
- Yeah, yeah exactly.
- Sorry I really just had to many.
So many moments where that happens.
- You came with a bit of
a chip on your shoulder.
- So how long do you think,
like currently I assume
you wanna continue to evolve
your content in some way.
- Definitely.
I definitely don't, as
much as it probably paints
some people to hear I don't
wanna just stick with hentai.
Cause you know, I have
other things I like to do.
I'm not nymphomaniac as
many people have alluded to.
- What are people's like assumption
on you based on your content.
- A lot of people have actually asked me,
it's like do you just like
have sex all the time?
Do you just read sex, is
that all you fucking do?
And then it's like, why
would you think that?
(indistinct)
- To you is it like, is hentai
now has your relationship
with like hentai changed?
Cause we were talking last
week about how our relationship
with anime has changed cause
even though we're still very
much enjoy it it is
part of the job as well.
- Yeah if anything, I
would say like my knowledge
and appreciation of it has grown deeper.
And just kind of like, it's more like...
I never really changed too
deeply but I would say in terms
of like enjoying it as sort of a hobby
now it's just kind of just reading it.
Not even just for like to get
horny or just like enjoy it.
- The last thing I want
is like I'm mid wank
and I'm thinking this is
gonna make a great video.
(laughing)
- That's thing where do
you ever get to the point
where you're just reading a
dogen and then in the back
of your mind you're
like, I could just read
this or I need to be reading
this because (indistinct).
- That actually kind of, that does suck.
Cause it's just sometimes
you're just like, okay,
all right I'm--
- I don't wanna ruin porn.
Not that I'm fond of it anyway.
I just don't want to form an attack.
- This is why I find it so
hard to stream sometimes.
Cause I like video games
is like my one last bastion
of like a hobby that I can just turn
to whenever maybe I'm
like burnt out anime.
- I get that, I do.
I think it's like 50, 50
for me on the video game.
But there's some video games
like League of Legends It's
just stressful to stream.
Cause like I'm entering,
I'm Owen eight on stream.
I'm laughing it off on
every single time I die.
You look at my eyes and
I'm like, Owen nine!
(laughing)
But playing Super Mario on
stream is chill as fuck.
- Gaming for me is half off
as well cause I don't stream
every game I play.
- Same, same, same.
- So some games I'm just
like I could have easily
fucking streamed Animal Crossing
for like five months
straight and being like,
yeah, that's content.
But that game is so personal to me
that I'm like I don't want to stream it.
That's just something that
I just wanna keep completely
separate from any monetary thing.
- Its not any Cole's party, right?
- Yeah right.
(laughing)
- If it's like Cole's party I'll be like
fuck y'all stream that shit.
It's fucking Cole's party.
I'm not gonna play Cole's party on my own.
Why the fuck I'm I gonna do that.
- I would argue there's some like,
even though gaming for
me is still like I try
to make it my personal thing.
There are some games
that I genuinely think
are better enjoyed with an audience.
- Oh, yeah!
- You agree?
- Yeah absolutely.
- I'm just trying to think of
some at the top of my head.
- I like Mario 64 like
when I streamed that shit.
- Oh my God!
- That shit was fucking fun.
Cause people are just giving me shit
for being like crap at the game.
And I'm like, you wanna
try and play this game off
to like a 15 year gap.
- Stuff, like Mario Party is
really fun being streamed.
- Mario Karts is really fun as well
- Mario Karts is fun streaming.
I think any game that has a
very easy to understand concept
with an immediate feedback
loop is like great.
The games where you have
to queue up five minutes
play for 40 minutes.
Like multiplayer games don't work for me.
I don't like watching other people
play league on stream really?
Except the LCS...
- Or the Worlds.
- Yeah Worlds.
- Because you started streaming
recently, right Sydney?
- Actually, before I started doing YouTube
I tried being a Twitch streamer full time.
- No way.
- Yeah.
For a good like five months.
- What did you stream?
- I would stream mostly Resident Evil.
- Really?
- I really liked shooting
games, cause it (screams)
(laughing)
(indistinct)
- That was back when we were
living in Thailand and Sydney
because of her visa status
she couldn't get like a proper job there.
So she would like try to
take any like odd jobs
or like contraction jobs there.
She could like on the side I was like
well you don't want to be a YouTuber.
Cause she was still kind of
scarred from the Leafy thing.
So I was like, why not try streaming?
- How did that go for you?
- It actually went okay.
Like I got five viewers.
(laughing)
I'm actually my mods
now that are like, man
my discord as well as like everything
or actually the people, the
five people from that time.
- Oh really?
(laughing)
(indistinct)
- The original five.
- I wanted to grow my
audience and the guns
like just try doing YouTube.
I'm like fuck.
All right, I'll do it.
And then just did YouTube.
(laughing)
- Do you plan to like
go back into streaming?
- Streaming is actually
a lot of work, isn't it?
- Oh yeah, I was gonna ask about that.
What do you think about
the whole streaming
versus YouTube debate?
Because they always fuck (indistinct).
- It's like all streamers
don't put any effort and the--
- The vice versa.
- Yeah vice versa.
- Streaming is hard, like streaming
you have to like talk
to people constantly.
You'd like be entertaining,
nonstop for hours
and hours and it constantly
it feels you're being like you
have to be excited, high peppered,
energetic otherwise you're boring.
- Yeah like if you had to pick,
if you say you were you
could be just successful
in either career choice being a YouTube
or a streamer putting in
the same amount of hours.
Which one would you prefer to be?
- YouTube, 100%.
100% YouTube.
- I think I would choose YouTube.
- 'Cause streaming it's like
every day it's constant.
- Yeah.
- I think I find streaming easy.
I can just chat shit for
like five hours, no problem.
- Yep well you're like one
of the most extroverted
introverts I've met.
Like there are times when I'm just like
I just don't wanna talk.
(laughing)
Especially when I'm streaming.
My stream limit was two
hours after two hours
I'm just like man, I hate talking,
leaving my mouth it just effort now.
I just love doing 24 hour streams.
I've done like five, I think in total.
- That sounds like torture to me.
- That sounds like torture.
- The last eight of six
hours are just pure pain
and the last two are
like, you're a zombie.
You forget I would be like,
oh I haven't spoke for a
minute, I'm sorry, chat.
- That's what it feels like though.
- But it's good 'cause
it gets people excited
'cause they know that
they can just turn it on.
But I don't know I find
streaming easy when I do it.
But the problem is that I don't know
how I could do it five days a week.
I like that with YouTube.
Okay I can work 14 hours a
day for a week if I want to.
But I can also just not work for a week.
If I've prepared properly
and I really love that flexibility.
And I feel like with streaming
even I've started getting
a little bit I'm like, wait,
why did I lose 200 subs
or haven't streamed in a week.
And then it's like, oh shit
am I getting that pressure?
- Yeah.
- I've gotta keep my subs up.
- You've to maintain your sub count.
- And it's almost like you're
gamifying it but it forces
like you see these streamers
like 12 hours a day,
the 12 hour streams a day like
four or five times a week.
And I'm like, that can't be healthy,
- They're just built for
that kind of stuff right?
It's just like they're built different.
(laughing)
- They're just built
different man, what can I say.
- Honestly, I really do
think that streaming--
- I think I'm gonna say
this and I'm gonna probably people off.
- I think streaming takes way less talent.
I think it just takes--
- A lot of patience.
- I think it takes a lot
of learning and effort.
I think anyone can be a streamer.
I think for some things on YouTube
it's a lot harder to succeed.
I think YouTube has
become very specialized.
- I dunno. I feel like,
I feel like it's like half and half.
Because I feel that with
streamers to stand out
in this day and age you have to be,
you have to have something
about you that makes
you stand out.
- Is true.
(indistinct)
- Yeah like you have to be Vtube.
even then, it's just a matter of time
for Vtube to get so oversaturated.
That it's gonna be--
- It's already happening.
- Yeah exactly, right.
I mean, that's why Hot Life have like a,
have a audition period.
It's no coincidence that
everyone in Hot Life is really,
really good at being entertaining
is because they auditioned for it.
- I'm not saying that like, you know
it requires no talent whatsoever.
I just think that the
barrier of entry to see,
I mean, even Twitch it's really hard
to get a good audience on.
YouTube it's easier to get
to the first thousand subs.
Whereas on Twitch, it's
hard to go from zero to 10.
Like that's hard.
- I just feel like with YouTube,
there's more opportunity for creativity.
'Cause with streaming you are
way more limited in your ideas
of what you can do and not
say you can't do like original
ideas, but you are way more limited
than what you can put
in the YouTube video.
- That's true, that's true.
But I don't know I feel YouTube
has become so competitive
recently to be even notable whatsoever.
- I'd argue Twitch is
even more competitive.
- Really you think so.
- I think Twitch is way more competitive.
- Okay, okay that's fair enough.
- I would have no idea how I
would go about growing myself
on Twitch if I wasn't already established.
- Yeah.
- I wouldn't either.
- Whereas on YouTube I'd
be like maybe I can do
an interesting video
idea or like taco taco
or certain topic in the way
in a way that no one else has.
- But let's be real when it
comes to Twitch like discovery.
- Oh, it's garbage.
- It's shit.
Like people don't go on
Twitch to watch VODs.
That's just not how it works.
- Isn't like to be a
successful Twitch streamer
is it the problem of I'm
not entertaining enough?
Or the algorithm is fucking me?
Like what's in the mix?
- It's a bit of both I reckon.
'Cause like, again it stems
down to that whole thing
of if you have more than
20 viewers in a stream,
every stream, then you'll technically
in the top 10% of Twitch.
- Yeah, right.
- There's just, anybody can do it.
But to maintain that level of
quality throughout the entire
time, I think it does take
a somewhat of a talent.
- There's a lot of streamers
like between 20 and 100
that just like you build
up that like audience
of just pure like commitment
just like constantly
interacting with them.
- Yeah.
- And I think to get to that
point is like just requires
just not being a dick and just dedication.
- Because I'll tell you
one of the big reasons
why I was able to get
into the Vtuber scene
versus like the live streaming scene
before Vtubers came along,
it's because what I couldn't
get into about streamers
is that there basically
always streaming, right?
There could be like
they could be streaming eight hours a day
so you can tune in any time
you want but you don't know
what they'll be doing.
Sometimes I'll be playing a certain game
then you know, I get
that you can just leave
them on in the background.
But I like having like a piece of content
that I know I can watch.
So with Vtubers most of their
streams are like one hours
or two hours long.
So it's just like very segmented.
So I know like, I know what
I'm getting out of a Vtuber
stream, you know, they're
going to be playing
for this set amount
and it's on a schedule.
They're going to be doing X
show or player playing X game.
And I can be like, okay
I'm gonna watch this Vtube
for this time and then I
could do something else.
Whereas with Twitch, it's just like
do I want to put them
on in the background?
You know, maybe, maybe not.
There's nothing that inherently draws me
to that content aside from if I really
liked their personality.
- And also much easier to like
watch back on VODs on YouTube
because YouTube is built
as a already prerecorded video service.
- Yeah.
- So it's just way
easier to like, go back.
Like if you missed a Vtuber stream
then it's so easy to just go
into the channel and just see
all the boards there like
a regular YouTube channel.
Whereas Twitch looking
through VODs is a fucking pain
in the ass because they've
set it up so shittily.
That's why everyone has
a highlights channel.
- Right, exactly.
- Yeah I wanna get as well.
(laughing)
- Yeah I saw someone started highlighting
your Twitch streams as well.
- Yeah they did, they did.
And I wanna basically just get one
where I can just like split
the ad rep with someone.
So it's like, all right, they just do it.
They get the address...
- Yeah.
(indistinct)
- Make content more because
I mean if I'm streaming
I may as well turn it into content, right.
If I have nothing to do with it, great.
I can just, you know, yeah I mean.
I mean yeah, I do think
that Twitch is fucking hard
to get the ball rolling.
- Yeah is brutal!
- I mean, I would say
that it's a skill set
that I don't have to be
successful on Twitch.
Like I understand how
the Twitch audience works
and like the kind of content they want
but that's the kind of
grind that I cannot do that.
- Yeah, like you're very like chill.
- Yeah.
My social skills come in bursts,
I say and so does my inspiration.
I don't know what it is.
I don't know if it's
the same with you guys
but either I'm working on like
five to 10 different projects
at once, or I'm like struggling
to think of one idea.
- Yeah.
- That's exactly.
I'm like, man, I got so
many good ideas and I know
that when I'm done with these ideas,
I'm like fuck what do I do next?
Which is why I would almost
like Twitch cause it's like
I never have to worry
about thinking of an idea
just put on chat shit, right.
Whereas with YouTube,
it's like fuck I gotta
keep one-upping myself.
I'm going to go stale.
It's like how can you go stale
if you're just playing games.
- Yeah.
- I mean, there probably
examples of it but yeah.
- So like how long do you, for example,
think you could like keep
doing YouTube or how long?
Cause you know I think--
(indistinct)
Cause I think every YouTube
it gets asked the question
like, oh where do you see
yourself in five years, 10 years.
Like that kind of stuff.
Which I think is the
stupidest question ever.
- I guess it's hard to kind of,
I guess what feels right you
know, just go with the wind.
Like, cause I definitely
don't feel like doing
I'm trying to like I have
plans to make my channel
not just hentai focused anymore.
I want to show off some
of my other talents
voice work, maybe if I'm talented.
But just like other things that I'm like
that are interesting in the anime sphere.
- Cause you've done a few
videos where you like go to,
you know, bars that have existed.
- Like that are featured in manga.
I honestly really love those
videos I guess just seeing
just me out and about, you know.
- Do you feel like you got
drawn into just making content
about hentai just because of
you saw how well it was doing
do you feel pressure about it?
- Of course, of course I
feel pressure about it.
Believe it or not do I always want to make
content just about hentai?
Of course not.
- It just gets sick!
(indistinct)
- Of course I enjoy it and I
wouldn't be making anything
I think is just for the view, for money.
(indistinct)
- Here's like a little trade secret
that I'm just gonna spill right now.
Like some of Sydney's videos,
some of Sydney videos
ideas have been ideas
that I've pitched to her
because sometimes I get ideas.
Sometimes I get ideas
and I'm like I can't
do this for my channel.
But like I live vicariously through Sydney
to be like, yo Sydney, I can't
do this idea for my channel
can you like do it?
Can you do me a good one?
- And I do it.
- Yeah, cause I remember
the one like the one
that Doujin I wanted to like get someone
to talk about was a
retake, which going back
to the fan fiction thing I
was talking about earlier
like this is the Doujinshi
that got me into thinking,
Hey, maybe fan fiction is not that bad.
Because this is retake to
explain to you is basically
just entire fucking retelling
of the end of Event Galleon.
Cause I remember when
I first watched the end
of Event Galleon as a kid and
I'm talking about the movie
as well, it is not a
satisfying conclusion.
If you don't understand what's happening.
And especially I have a
deeper appreciation of end
of Ava now as an adult, but as a kid,
I'm just like I just
wanna see what happens.
And then through that I discovered retake
and retake is one of the
most satisfying fan fictions
I have ever where it kind
of ties up every loose ends
that's I wanted to be tied
up in when I was watching
the original Ava.
And it gave me the same kind of conclusion
and satisfaction within myself
that I would have felt even
if it was just a cannon, like in my head
it is kind of just cannon.
- I watched your video about it.
So that's the reason why I know it exists.
- Yeah, cause Garnt kind of like--
- And then I got to it to read it.
- We actually had to
watch Event Galleon first.
Cause I never really watched Event Galleon
probably till recently.
And then he showed me retake
and we shared the exact
same opinions on it.
Like, so yeah.
- Well that's true.
(laughing)
(indistinct)
- We came at the exact same time.
- Oh my God you skipped
the blow jobs to, same.
- And I'm like, yo Sydney
why didn't you make a video about this?
- And I'm like Oh my God Sydney
why don't you make a video.
- And so you did.
- So I did.
(indistinct)
- I might be honest, I'm
like his little entertainer
and he's my agent but
we have like a little
like sexy relationship.
- You did it, you really
didn't have to say it.
(laughing)
- Where are you really gonna
do me like this Sydney?
- All I asked was what are you doing?
(laughing)
I don't know why I went to that direction.
- How is this camera have
like 10 times more wholesome.
- I don't know how to do it.
Oh my God.
- Oh my God!
- Is there anything
else you want to mention
or anything else you want to talk about?
- Anything you want me to
pretend to like ask you about.
(indistinct)
- Just ask me what jobs
did I have previously?
- What jobs did you have
previously, I'm curious.
(laughing)
- McDonald's cool, thank you.
- I don't know what you're
actually asking about.
(indistinct)
- Okay, when I was in high school
my first job was at a frozen yogurt place.
And then I moved to England--
- That is the widest
thing you've ever said.
- Is that it, can you elaborate
more on the frozen yogurt.
- It wasn't very long.
- Did anything happen, how
long were you there for?
- Four or five months.
- And nothing interesting.
- Then I graduated in high school
and then I started working
at a bakery at a supermarket
and then before I graduated
high school supermarket bakery
and then I moved to England
and I started working at Wetherspoons.
Worst job I've ever had, I hated it.
It's if you guys know what
Wetherspoons is it's this cheap.
I think you guys mentioned it.
- Yeah we mentioned it.
- The old people there
would start at like 8:00 AM
and they'd always come in
with like the first thing
they'd always order is shots
of like whiskey or vodka
and they just keep going.
- All old British people
are like I don't know
what's wrong, man.
They always go to the pub at like 9:00 AM
to meet up with the other old friends.
And they just get drunk.
That's all they do every week.
- And they were mean, they were mean.
They'd be like, you
shouldn't be in our country.
You're not like, they were pretty mean.
I got screamed at everyday.
Sometimes I'd cry and they'd be like,
oh no you're just trying
to make me feel bad.
I'm just like, you just
told you don't like me,
you called me a bitch.
- Yes, you should feel bad.
- Yeah.
- And sometimes I pour a beer like not,
cause I didn't really like
know how to pour beer.
- Pouring a pine is a
very strict procedure.
- Yeah!
- And they would be just
like you damn bitch.
And I'm like...
- And an old British man
would call you a dumb bitch.
No way.
- They only called me a bitch.
- A bitch, but a damn bitch.
(laughing)
- Bitch I can see but damn bitch, nah!
That's to far.
- I'll slice that half.
(laughing)
- And then just like sometimes I actually,
when we moved to Thailand, I did--
- That's when you kind
of tried to dip your job,
dip your foot into like a lot of things.
Do you want to talk about that time
where you were an English teacher?
- You were an English teacher?
- I was an English teacher in Thailand.
So Garnt's family had like a friend
and I would like,
it was allowed in the country for like me
to kind of help with the kids.
It was all right, I wasn't being illegal,
you know stealing Thai people's money.
But I was an English teacher for children
from the ages of one to four.
- So you're basically a daycare.
- Basically sounds like daycare.
- Yeah, like I would just like
kind of did that is it's a bit exhausting.
- I remember the very
first English teaching job
she had, so to to preface
Sydney loves dogs.
Like whenever she sees
a dog, like you can hear
it in a voice because like up,
up, the pitch in her voice.
- She reaches a frequency
that only dogs can dog hear.
(laughing)
- Is like (screaming softly)
- Dog whistle.
- Yeah, exactly.
It's like her voice goes into
like dog whistle territory.
I remember the first day on the job,
she was like dreading it.
And I remember I had to
drive her to this house
where she had to tutor these kids.
- A private tutor for
like kids that were age
seven and eight and I was like
I don't want to go to
like these strangers house
that they would like rape and kill me?
And I was like, ah, but it's also 8:00 AM
and I don't wanna go.
- Yeah so she was like
complaining the entire way
there to be like maybe I should quit now.
I'm just going to quit.
Like I'm gonna go there,
I'm gonna look the person
in the eye and I'm going to be like,
you know what this job's not for me.
So we pull up to this house and it's like
a gated house with like a patio on it.
And there are just these puppies.
- Puppies, they were just
born, there were a week old.
- There are just these puppies
just sitting in this patio.
- At the moment Sydney looked at them,
all of the windows in the
neighborhood shattered.
(laughing)
- And she was like (stammering)
those are puppies right there.
And then a woman comes
out and it was like,
oh are you the teacher?
- Already knows the house and I'm like...
(laughing)
- I love this job.
- Give me those puppies,
like ten of them and I'm like
give me the babies.
- You're just teaching English
while you're holding like four puppies.
- Oh my God.
- It's why, why?
- Like, why are you so--
- Puppy.
- Puppy, that's your English.
- And I'd never seen Sydney,
out of the car as fast
as I had, as she had just
realized this was the house
that she was about to teach in.
- So fucking sweet, just ah!
And then obviously I
hated English teaching.
Probably not the best.
- I was gonna say that,
didn't think your English
was that good to teach English.
- What the fuck does that mean.
Cause I could say words like
baby bit for small like.
- High penetration. (laughs)
Repeat after me.
(laughing)
- Like going back to
your, like your wee phase
one thing I am kind of jealous
of now that like living
in Japan is that you have like no fear
when it comes to attempting Japanese
or like trying Japanese
and everything like that.
- Be like (speaking foreign language)
(laughing)
Do you hear me?
- No of that.
But you have like no fear when it comes
to like attempting your Japanese.
And there have been times
when before we moved to Japan.
Cause I remember you
were telling me the story
about when I had my signing
at Book Walker at AIX.
And you actually met one
of the authors there.
- I don't think there was
the Don Lochia, I don't know.
I think I was, was it the one.
It was like the second time I met you
it was my older brother.
- It might've been Master Musume.
- I didn't honestly accept
it I know you introduced me
but I was like a bit drunk.
Because we were day drinking. (laughs)
- Do you wanna explain the story?
- So I was at an Anna come
with my Oni Chan, my brother.
- You could have just said brother.
(laughing)
- I'm out.
- And all of us like we went with a group
going with Garnt, our
friends, some of her friends
from England and my brother
wanted to come cause
he likes going to anime cons as well.
And I'm really close with my brother.
So he came with us to AX and
we were like day drinking.
- How did she do it?
(indistinct)
- You got her to get through those lines.
- Yeah.
- Oh my God.
(indistinct)
- And Garnt had a signing at
Book Walker not long after.
And I was like about
four or five beers deep.
And that might as well be lethal,
(laughing)
(indistinct)
it was like 4:00 PM.
Okay so I went in the back
behind the Book Walker
signing thing and--
- I was having my signing.
- Yeah but someone else
has finished their signing
and I was with my brother
and I was bit drunk,
you know, I'm not gonna lie.
And so Meilyne obviously, which
you guys obviously remember
from previous episodes was
there and she was like,
oh do you to meet this guy's name
whose I don't even remember?
And I'm just like, sure.
But I was pretty obviously
drunk and I shook his hand.
(mocking sounds)
And as you're speaking shity Japanese
as this just (speaking foreign language)
And we were just like this...
(laughing)
And this guy's like, all right.
And then later did I find
out that was Monster Musume.
- Oh my God.
- I also have another story.
- Go ahead.
- All right go ahead.
- I just wanna say this
is actually the coolest
one and I need this.
Okay, so we were at the
Funimation party at HAX 2017, 18.
And I think it was 18.
- It was like two years ago, I think.
- Yeah.
So we were drinking in it
and I obviously had to go
to the bathroom and they only
had one bathroom in the place.
- This was the Funimation party.
- I did mention that.
- Okay, sorry.
- So I went in and then I
see this guy just laying
on the floor in there and I'm
just like I kind of get up
and I wake him up.
- So was he in the women's toilet?
- There was only one toilet.
- Oh okay.
- And he was just like faced
out, I thought he was dead.
I thoughts, like he over drank
or he was like dead or something.
Cause he was face down in
the middle of the toilet
and he wasn't moving and
I kept waking you up.
And then I just kinda kept shaking him
and then he's just like I realized
cause he starts speaking Japanese.
He's a Japanese guy, right.
And then I was just like--
- Normally, normally.
- He's just like in the most
like really broken English.
He's like, I'm one of the
animators for Boku no hero.
I'm like, can you get
the out of the bathroom?
(laughing)
- I don't care who you're I need to piss.
- He was like, when can I see you again?
I'm like who the fuck are you?
- He just told you he is an
animator for Boku no hero.
- Because the guests are
some of the animators
from Boku no hero were there.
And he's just there,
I'm like are you okay?
Can you just get out?
I had to take a piss dude.
And he's just like, can I see you again?
I'm like just get the fuck out.
(laughing)
- I have to take a shit.
- But he was like, I felt bad
cause he's like obviously really wasted.
- Yeah we all have.
- We've all been there,
we've all been there.
- Some more than once.
- So yeah. I think we've told
enough stories for a lifetime.
Is there anything you
want to like shout out
I guess on your side of things.
Cause you are technically
a guest of the show.
- Even though we see each other,
(instinct)
- Please subscribe to Sydsnap and--
- What a marketing genius.
(laughing)
If you wanna check out Sydney stuff
her stuff's is in the description.
- Check the link in the
screen, I'll shout out for you.
You can check out Sydney
at youtube.com/sydsnap,
twitter.com/sydsnap.
- He is a man having to do everything.
(indistinct)
- Check out the description you fuckers!
- It's all in the description.
Hey, but also thank you to
our patreons for supporting
the show as always look
at all these lovely names.
- Oh look at those lovely
names, beautiful name.
- I love them so much.
- I bought 10 times this guy.
(laughing)
- I wish this guy, this
guy enjoys the plot.
I know he does.
(indistinct)
- If you'd like to support
the show, then as always go
to patreon.com/trashtastes.
Have your names come on the screen.
- Exactly and help us create
some more cool content.
Also make sure to check out our Twitter
and subreddit as always.
That is also in the description below.
And hey, you're probably wondering
about the shirts that we're all wearing.
- Yes, we did mention this last time
but this is your last week to get it.
You can click in the link description
or go to Joey I forgot the URL.
- It bakuretsu.co/trashtaste
- Sign now they won't be here again.
So get it now while you still can.
- By the time the next episode comes out
these shirts will be unavailable
and they're probably
not going to come back.
So if you'd like to grab
them limited edition stuff--
- First edition Trash Taste shirts.
- First edition Trash Taste
go check it out again.
- Thank you very much
Sydney for joining us today.
(indistinct)
- Oh my God.
- All right.
- That's the end, bye.
- She is never coming back.
- Bye.
(laughing)
(bright upbeat music)